okay
thank you all for coming and um please
introduce yourselves and spell your name
for our Claire if necessary
good morning thank you Mr chairman
members of the committee for the
opportunity to present this morning for
the record my name is Jared chicoine I'm
the commissioner of the New Hampshire
Department of energy shacoin has felt
c-h-i-c-o-i-n-e
uh joining me today is Lenny radio our
business director
um I also have with us today Josh
Elliott our director of policy and
programs and David shulock our general
counsel okay thank you
do you want to start with your
presentation sure yeah I'd just like to
provide an overview of the department
um the New Hampshire Department of
energy is New Hampshire's newest state
agency and was created in the last state
budget
our statute states that the department
is to quote improve the administration
of state government by providing unified
Direction on policies programs and
Personnel in the field of energy and
utilities making possible increased
efficiency and economies from integrated
Administration and operation of the
various energy and utility related
functions of the state government end
quote
part of the intent of the legislation
was to allow the puc to focus on their
regulatory adjudicative responsibilities
and to make clear the separation between
the state's regulatory advocacy role and
the impartial role that the puc plays
the department of energy has a large and
diverse set of responsibilities the
creation of the department involved the
reorganization of the Public Utilities
Commission and the dissolution of the
office of strategic initiatives
we're joined by our colleagues from our
administratively attached agencies the
Public Utilities Commission the Office
of Consumer Advocate and the site
evaluation committee
each of these agencies is independent of
the department we don't direct them to
do anything
um we simply how are we simply helping
perform various back office budgetary
and administrative functions
you'll hear from them following my
presentation
the department of energy fills a wide
variety of roles in the field of energy
this diversity of responsibilities is
reflected in our mission statement
which reads as follows the prosperity
and security of New Hampshire and its
citizens requiring affordable Innovative
reliable and sustainable energy economy
the department of energy is committed to
achieving that goal and will provide a
unified direction of energy policies
responsible and practical programs
principled regulation and skilled
representation in energy relating energy
related proceedings of New Hampshire's
public interest the department of energy
will serve the people of New Hampshire
in an honest transparent and effective
manner
let me talk just for a moment about some
of those responsibilities the department
of energy is an automatic party at
proceedings before the puc where we fill
a record building and advocacy role this
is where we get into the setting of the
rates that our electric natural gas and
water customers pay unlike many others
many other of the regulatory activities
in state government we are not
regulating individuals and small
businesses we're regulating large
government guaranteed natural monopolies
the effects of our regulation involve
direct Financial impacts on what every
citizen pays for necessary Services the
puc is the adjudicative body that makes
decisions in rate proceedings and the
doe and the Office of Consumer Advocate
work hard in those proceedings to build
the record and advocate in the interests
of New Hampshire
we administer Assistance programs and
other energy related programs let me ask
a short question about that so so
essentially the puc is like the judge
correct in a rate setting situation
you're one side and the utility is the
other side yes we're helping to build
the record uh in those proceedings yes
okay the the PCS are the adjudicators
gotcha
so we administer Assistance programs and
other energy related programs mostly
that use federal funds you can see many
of the programs that we administer on
the handout that we provided for each of
you we also provide support to consumers
in dealing with utility companies and
take in consumer complaints against
utilities
we have a substantial role in utility
safety and enforcement of the state's
law rules and regulations
we've also been given a strong policy
role which includes the creation of the
10-year State energy strategy and
providing Technical and policy advice to
the legislature
we also play a major role in Regional
discussions collaborations and
negotiations with the other states in
our region
as all of New England is part of the
same electric grid the decisions of
other states can affect New Hampshire
the department of energy is statutorily
obligated to defend New Hampshire's
interests from shifting from the
shifting of costs that result from other
states policy decisions
in putting together our budget proposal
our primary goal has been to take
advantage of the creation of the
Department of energy to find operational
efficiencies and manage through
significant challenges in the field of
energy
our budget represents 67.5 million
dollars in FY 24 and 67.9 million
dollars in fy25
as a part of our effort to find
efficiencies we proposed a budget that
decreases 1.4 percent in FY 24 and about
one percent in fy25 as compared to the
FY 23 adjusted authorized
it's due in large part to the
abolishment of seven positions in this
budget
our budget is about 87 percent Federal
in other funds those other funds include
Reggie and the renewable energy funds
about 12 to 13 percent is utility
assessment and six tenths of a percent
General funds
about 80 percent of our funds are passed
through grants that represent
either Assistance programs or rate payer
rebates
um other than these funds we administer
and send out uh
we're other than these funds that we
send out through these programs uh the
department is very much uh people
focused agency
our team is comprised of many very
technical highly skilled and in-demand
workers lawyers economists analysts
Auditors engineers and many others
energy is a complex and Niche field with
many opportunities in the private sector
that pay substantially more than the
state our team members are here truly as
public servants they are people who want
to be here and serve the rate payers and
consumers of New Hampshire
I'm very proud of our team and how
they've responded to the significant
challenges over these last couple of
years
and just a moment on those challenges
when the department was created there
was a great deal of effort to implement
the transition which was expected
um but still difficult this included the
turnover of a great deal of
institutional knowledge and Technical
capabilities but it has really
highlighted the importance of
maintaining our Workforce recruiting and
retention is a real challenge as I'm
sure you've heard from other agencies
we've lost several employees to
utilities and even to other states
Regulatory Agencies just to give you an
example of the five hearings examiners
their attorneys we have in our
Administration division we've lost three
in just over a year uh two have gone to
utilities and one went to ISO New
England the grid operator
I'm sure the consumer Advocate will be
able to tell you a similar story the
training of individual staff represents
expensive and and time-sensitive
Investments uh by the state that that
get lost if that employee leaves
there are only a few alternatives to
retaining our expert Talent we can hire
expensive Consultants who do a good job
at a price significantly higher
in many instances than what an in-house
expert would provide
or we can let the and if we don't do
that we're essentially letting the the
regularly regulated utilities
um run unchecked so um it's important
that that we retain uh experienced and
qualified staff
outside of those administrative
challenges we're also dealing with the
cost and energy security challenges
that are not just a state problem
they're a regional National and global
there are aspects of these crises that
we can control and aspects that we can't
but but we've endeavored to do our part
but this has affected every part of our
business from the regulation of
utilities to our Assistance programs to
consumer complaints and hardships
finally and this is an opportunity as
much as it is a challenge but there's an
absolutely staggering amount of federal
funding for energy and climate issues
that has been passed over the last few
years in Congress
with the opportunity for funding has
come many changes restrictions and
compliance requirements that represent
significant costs and Staffing
if New Hampshire is going to be able to
take advantage of these funds we will
have to be staffed adequately and
appropriately
and just uh to add to that we have
requested and it has been approved by
fiscal at least two full-time temporary
positions uh to help us administer those
new federal funds that are coming
um commissioner let me stop you for a
moment
um representative Griffin has to leave
shortly and he was making some body
language that I thought he'd make one
day and ask a question so
and I'm finished okay
yeah I I think I as you went on I got to
answer my question it basically my
question was what are you doing to
retain
staff and what can we do to help you
retain staff sure
um what we've tried to do um I I think
as as an administrator is create an
environment
um uh where folks are able to uh grow in
their career right so we try to take
advantage of additional training
opportunities uh for staff where
possible
we've also
um to sort of keep up with
um what's happening in the private
sector we have allowed a limited uh
telework arrangement for some employees
I I would add that the the raise that
the governor has proposed for state
employees I feel that that would help
with retention so that's just a handful
of things that we've been focused on
thank you thank you now you said you
were you were reducing number of
positions a bit are those all vacant
positions
um they they currently are yes now
um on the budget uh I believe the last
foreign
it says you have
70 positions being reduced to 66.
and eight unclassified being reduced to
seven yes
is that right yes that's correct okay
good
um now
um
I I guess I'm used to asking questions
first but maybe in this role I should
we're okay okay all right so
um so let's look at slightly higher on
there so so
um you're adding
there's something in 23 for General
funds that wasn't actually used in 22
and then there's there's a little bit
left over what are those things do you
know so in in 23
um we did use those uh General funds to
as a match to one of our federal
programs the state energy program
um in particular for
um the position in our office of
offshore wind development
okay and that match is going getting
smaller is a kind of what's Happening
yes all right but there were other those
funds were carried over from understand
from when we were the the office of
strategic initiatives so yes over time
we'll be using less General funds
now
um
so you actually spent
uh this 53 million and 22 but but the
the following numbers are are
considerably higher 15 million higher 14
or 15. are you planning to getting close
to those numbers is is something new
happening I'll let Lenny get into the
details but um some of that is our
vacancies right um as we were created as
a department there are new unclassified
positions that weren't filled for some
time
um and and others but I'll let uh I'll
let Lenny get into the weeds one of the
major differences that you can see here
is the uh the actuals for the federal
funds in 2022 compared to what we have
audited for 2023. um the reason for that
is because we have we had about 35
million dollars worth of arpa funds
which is not in the budget
um so and we had to spend those down
first before we could spend our normal
program year for like um the low-income
heating assistance programs things like
that so a lot of those those that 35
million was spent first and now we're
just um and some of those funds were
carried forward into FY 23 and we're
spending those funds now so although
there's actual expense less than what we
budgeted this this is the about the
normal amount that we'll be spending in
23 of what is budgeted
okay and other funds are going down by
seven or six or seven something like
um
so like for the uh the um the Reggie the
regional greenhouse gas initiative
that's one of our our major other funds
um that fluctuates from year to year
depending on the regional auctions for
buying um basically buying pollution
um certificates and that flux that's
going to fluctuate from year to year
it's a continually appropriated
non-lapsing fund so we can adjust during
the year
um so we may see a lot and as you can
see in um in 22 it was 39 million in in
23 it's you know we've just budgeted 32
million and 33 and um 24. so we kind of
try to keep it historical but there's
going to be years where that number will
fluctuate up and down
especially when you can looking at
actuals
now is this the money that we return to
Consumers
yes we rebate those suppose back to the
rate payers but it sort of it flows
through your Facebook and a portion of
that I should add a portion that does go
to Energy Efficiency programs but the
vast majority
is rebated to rate pairs is it like 80
20 or something
um it's not even more like 90 10 90 10
yeah okay
I think we have a bill about that yeah
all right
um
is there other things in this other
category besides Reggie yes there's the
renewable energy fund which is a little
bit less and that's
um payments from the utilities for
alternative compliance payments
um that's around you can see that in uh
if you um page back a few pages that's
in accounting unit 1890. those are also
other funds and then the assessment that
we charge
um the regular utilities for the
remaining of our payroll and expenses
that's also makes up the other funds all
right so you mentioned this utility
assessment right what is that so that is
the amount that we charge the utilities
for the work that the department and it
also of what OCA and the puc the puc
does
so is that a little line on your
electric bill or is it
somehow in the folded into the price it
is it is folded into uh into your bill
yes okay and I think David it's in the
Tariff right
um
specified
sense
so about 33 cents a month for the
average residential rate pair I see okay
not not a big number
um all right
so looking at
let's talk about these um Grant programs
because looking at your page your pie
charts here
um it looks like 80 percent of what your
money it goes to Grants
right
contract is Grant our grant funded
um
so what are the what are what are the
major programs there so one was rebates
to Consumers on Reggie and the other
major programs and give us some numbers
about so many million for this so I'm
sure so we have um uh there are several
federally funded programs that we
administer number the first one and
largest would be
um the low-income home energy assistance
program LIHEAP we refer to that as fuel
assist the fuel assistance program
um
on average the federal government grants
us uh about between 25 and 30 million
dollars
um per program year for that program
um we also have the weatherization
assistance program which that Grant on
an annual basis is roughly
one one and a half million dollars
um
we have the uh the shop Grant and I'm
Lenny you'll have to help me with the
total on that every year I forget the
exact amount of that Grant it's small
it's small it's only around um 100 000.
right and then we also have
um we also receive the pipe from the
pipeline hazardous materials safety
administration
um a grant to
um uh fund our pipeline safety program
um as well as it's about 500 000
annually and uh as well as the one call
Grant which is Dig Safe and that's
considerably smaller a little less than
fifty thousand
so Dig Safe is all paid by the FED I
don't know yes it's it's Federal yes
it's uh and there's also 70 so there's
less than one person about 30 paid from
the actual like the uh the major gas
pipelines
um we can only we can only charge them
the portion for the for the enforcement
of those Dig Safe
um charges
for fifty thousand you have one person
right well that's the that's actually
the non-gas portion of the devastate
program for like water lines and sewage
lines and electric lines and stuff but
the majority of the Dig Safe program is
for natural gas I see which is paid by
the utility no uh it's paid by the feds
mostly about 70 and then 30 is paid by
the those actual gas pipelines all right
well let's talk about the big item which
is low income fuel assistance so my
understanding is right now the cost of
heating oil is double what it was a year
ago
right the average price per gallon as of
this week I think is four dollars and 45
cents per gallon wow for oil in New
Hampshire and so how does that affect
this program is is this like totally run
out of money or is it
no
um we have been
um to give you an example the average
benefit for last year's program year 22
winter 21 22 is about a thousand dollars
per per household that was the average
um we we feel that you know last winter
we certified around 25 000 households
Statewide for the program uh we had
adequate funding uh we're up this year
considerably
um I I expect we'll be closer to 30 000
households enrolled and Josh and uh Josh
Elliott can can uh back me up on some of
these numbers
um I I do feel we have adequate funding
we were able to carry forward a
considerable portion of the grant we
received for for last winter for program
year 22 plus we received our regular
allocation for program year 23 this
winter
um
so we we feel that we do have adequate
funding
um we did increase the benefit because
of these higher costs
um about 20 I believe uh and um we also
Congress passed uh late last year in in
the federal budget an additional six
billion dollars for the LIHEAP program
so we expect if they use the same
formula
um that will receive an additional 25
million very soon for the program so I
feel like we do have adequate funding
um based on you mean it could double is
that what you're saying yes oh okay I
see now how does what's the mechanics of
that program how does somebody apply
sure what how do they qualify so the the
agency we contract with the five
Community Action agencies uh they are a
sub grantee for the program they do all
of the application intake that process
so if someone needs to apply for fuel
assistance they can go to their local
Community Action Agency they can apply
the process of of getting that
application through is handled by the
cap
and essentially what we do is we
reimburse the Caps they invoice Us in
the winter during the season on a weekly
basis we pay those invoices but they
really handle the entire process at the
Community Action Agency
no I meant
what level of income what level system
of course right I'm sorry so
um the program were allowed
um to uh certified households up to 60
percent of the state median income
yeah representative yes didn't we pass
in for folks between 60 and 75
um because just hearing back from
constituents there seemed to be uh
I don't know a halting uh procedure for
getting the funds out to the caps for
those people in that higher margin so
one of the questions I was going to ask
you was how that was going sure
um so when the legislature passed that
the legislation to enable that program
in September of last year we moved as
quickly as we possibly could as a
department anytime you have to stand up
a new program like this that's that's
needed immediately that's a challenge
um we contracted the legislation passed
mid-september and signed into law by the
governor we contracted with the Caps to
administer that new program at I believe
the the first executive council meeting
in October
uh we had to develop software
uh for that program
um for the Caps uh so between September
um and I believe it was the end of
December when we paid out some of the
first benefits under that program
um it's challenging
um you have to have an application
process you have to protect against
potential fraud so we essentially
mirrored uh the requirements of LIHEAP
in terms of the application process so
they come in they apply as if they're
applying for LIHEAP and if they are over
income and fall within the guidelines of
the new program they would be certified
to receive that benefit
um
with the increased numbers of
applications this winter for LIHEAP and
all types of assistance
um it has been a challenge for the
Community Action agencies they're doing
their very best they're working through
it but there's just a lot of demand
follow-up yes
so I
or that was just sort of
for how long period for the 60 to 75
percent the program ends June 30th or I
should say the program closes April 30th
um but the program ends uh June 30th so
anything left over with laps back to the
general fund and just one more the
electrical benefit that's being
administered through the utility
companies or does it go through the Caps
um and pull through the through the Caps
so that's a 200 benefit for every
household that qualifies
um and um that is administered by the
caps and those payments are made to the
utilities
there was because they were involved
yeah okay representative cameras
thank you Mr chair
um what percentage of a dollar do would
the Caps take uh somebody must pay them
to be the middleman so out of every
dollar that's funded do they get a
percentage of that or are you con you
said you contract with them what are
they paid
um I don't know if I could do the math
right now we could get that for you um
but the federal government allows 10
percent uh to be used for admin and um
Lenny yep so the uh 10
um for the total Grant is used for admin
and about 8.5 percent of that is the the
Caps we use and then we'll use the rest
the rest of it for our own
administrative costs we have two
full-time employees at the department
and so I heard I saw the they started at
60 of State median income
and what what do they receive is it
based on their usage do they show you a
fuel Bill and they get a percent of it
or how does it work there's a matrix uh
Inc that includes um to determine the
benefit the type of fuel that they use
um
yeah average heating costs
all right so this is this is a uh would
you say 25 or 30 million so this is half
your agency or something
um
what it what is what else is is large
ready uh Reggie red large of course
that's primarily a rebate to races just
a direct pay right okay
all right
um anybody else like to ask
yes representative evil
um I wanted to talk a little bit about
red G and the renewable portfolio so I
don't know I'm not a
energy geek but I hear a lot about
wrecks and all those sorts I'm just
curious there's continuing interest in
reducing the amount that goes to Energy
Efficiency programs and more and more
being paid out to rate payers I just
wondered if you could comment on that
how it affects your agency your programs
and any thoughts you might want to share
on it
I'm assuming I I don't know that you
take positions on those bills I would
guess you don't I mean I no
um it's a question for policy makers
it's a question for the legislature and
the governor on whether they want to
make changes
um to the renewable portfolio standard
you know our sustainable energy division
is is funded by those ACP payments
related to that program so obviously
there's an impact the agency of changes
are made but um really questions around
uh what should be rebated uh what should
go to programs I think really is a
question for for the legislature
are there new federal grants in this
area that you know all this latest
spending on this kind of stuff there are
numerous new federal programs or funding
opportunities around energy everything
from uh Green Banks so finest financing
dollars to
um rebate programs for Energy Efficiency
purchases for customers
um
uh there are dollars for uh grid
Innovation projects uh so those projects
related to transmission
um so there's uh numerous uh new types
of funding that's coming in and we're
doing our very best to track all of that
um you know we have new guidance coming
out frequently from the federal
government we are prepared again we've
we've tried to staff up with full-time
temporary positions to help us
administer funds that are coming
um so it's it's it's considerable tens
of millions of dollars for New Hampshire
and new federal funding
do do we who makes the decision to join
such a program you know there's a new
program for wind or something who makes
the decision to
to do that so if it's formula funding
for instance through existing grants
that we administer the state energy
program is a good example
um those are formula grants we're going
to accept that funding we're going to
use it
um and there may be some flexibility for
the state and and how we um utilize
those funds
um for competitive
opportunities where we'd have to submit
an application and a competitive Grant
process we have to look at a couple
things right
um we're going to try to pursue as much
of this as we can so that the taxpayers
of New Hampshire receive those benefits
um but there may be funding
opportunities that from a policy
perspective
um don't match with the goals of our
state energy strategy
um and there may be some that um
may not just make sense for our state
for a number of reasons but but I do
want everyone to know that we're going
to pursue as much of this funding as we
possibly can
um and would be happy to keep everyone
representative Sweeney thank you very
much I want to first thank you both for
being here today I'm sort of similar on
that same topic of competitive
opportunities I believe either last year
or the year before the federal
government put together funding for
hydrogen hubs around the country you had
mentioned New England being all sort of
in there together has there been any
conversation with the other New England
states about a New England or Northeast
hydrogen hub from that project there
there has been so the state of New York
um has been the lead on a on a regional
Northeast Regional hydrogen Hub
um we've had conversations with nyserda
which is the energy office in New York
about that
um
there are some steps we would need to
take to officially join and we've been
reviewing those
um our general counsel has been working
with us on that
um and uh we we've been trying to work
regionally on these opportunities
um so yes we are interested in that we
want to make sure that we're being
helpful and that our region is receiving
the benefits of of this Federal funding
for Innovation and energy
so I'll keep you posted on that if you'd
like um but we are having those
is there any progress on getting more uh
natural gas into the state and or more
so on natural gas
um
as I'm sure you've seen in the news we
are constrained uh when it comes to
natural gas capacity in the region
um very unlikely that we would see
increased natural gas capacity over a
pipeline and there are a number of
reasons for that
um
uh
policies in other states that that are
neighbors to us
um but then there's also just challenges
around citing new infrastructure and
that's not just one State's challenge
that's
every state into England and the
Northeast faces those challenges so
um I'm not sure that we would see in the
current environment unlikely
um that we would have how about lmg
so on LNG
um also another Topic in the news uh
over the last number of months
um uh the Everett LNG terminal in Boston
um you know currently that facility in
the Mystic generating facility that's
that's connected to it District Gas
um currently they're under a cost of
service agreement a reliability must run
agreement with ISO New England because
they were uh threatening retirement
essentially
um and so we've had them under the RMR
for this last winter for this current
winter and that agreement
ends that contract ends the end of May
2024.
so as a region the governor has been out
front on this we are working with our
neighboring states on what are the
potential Solutions as it relates to LNG
storage in the region in particular uh
the Everett marine terminal
question on natural gas who's What
entity is the largest consumer or who
absorbs most of that from the pipeline
is there so I think in New Hampshire it
would be
um the natural gas generators of
electricity would be the largest and and
then of course you'd have
um commercial industrial customers that
use gas and then residential in in FMA
is there
how is it allocated who determines or
how is it determined who gets what
because again there's a lot I mean if
more was available it would benefit
everybody but how is that determined who
gets what sure so so the uh the the
local distribution companies
um The Gas Utilities they have firm
contracts for gas
um the generators of electricity do not
they they buy it in the market right so
they don't have firm contracts for that
um but that's essentially how
um it's utilized so if I may say if uh
what used to be
um Sayer look well
um what used to be public service in New
Hampshire
um eversourced now
um they have a heavy Reliance I suspect
on natural gas for their production how
do they ensure that they all have ample
supply for what they need to do or is
there a way that they do that how in
other words there's only so much in the
pipeline so to speak and everybody's
aware of how much is available
so
um say if I was a heavy user that I
would make every effort to kind of have
a contract for as much of that as
possible
um
protecting my my resource and I may not
how is that handled I mean is it is it
just
what happens then because again if if
it's contracted for they can't allocate
it to the homeowners over in this
community that has to go here so what
happens
particularly if it's not consumed by
that person that is our entity that's
absorbing a great deal of it so I would
just go back to and and hopefully this
is the answer you're looking for but but
the the uh
the local distribution companies so
Liberty Utilities
um Unitil that have uh residential gas
customers they're Contracting
um those are firm contracts for the gas
they need to serve their customers
um I would have to to go beyond that I
would need one of my gas analysts to get
in the Weeds on all of that
um but if if you're a residential uh
utility customer that uses natural gas
um your utility has contracted for that
uh and then for Generation because the
utilities no longer own electric
Generation
Um you know those generators are
purchasing
um you know that uh that gas
uh in the marketplace and they don't
representative cameras thank you Mr
chair uh as far as energy Innovation
funds and looking at you know new types
of energy are you doing anything with
new nuclear technologies such as molten
salt reactors
so as a department we've participated I
believe there is currently
um a a commission a legislative
committee commission that was created
and we are represented on that
commission
um uh as a resource but as a department
we're not pursuing
um anything specifically related uh to
new nuclear
um
we think it's important that it's like
any other
um
generating resource that uh New
Hampshire
uh has an all of the above approach
right so we would want to encourage
exploration of of any new technology
um but we don't have plans
um
as it relates to nuclear
you do work on a 10-year uh plan though
so I would imagine something like that
would be included it could be yes and
and in our current strategy again we um
we support uh policy that would be fuel
neutral right so that we're not uh
advantaging any one uh type of energy
over another
um so uh it's an all of the above
approach and I think we also mentioned
in the strategy the importance of uh of
Seabrook uh to uh the generating mix in
the region so
um
we're always open to suggestions uh from
the legislature if you think that there
are uh particular areas of that
technology that we should uh you think
we should
um
do more investigation or provide uh more
information to policy makers like
yourself we're happy to happy to do that
so in general New Hampshire is the
fastest growing state in New England I
believe in terms of population and so on
right and so therefore I would assume
that energy demand
is rising the fastest here but because
we're part of iso New England and maybe
other places are declining dude is the
is the kind of total amount of power
well um you know the way we're Regional
grid right so electricity flows to where
to where it's needed right
um and uh you know on resource adequacy
which I think is what what you're uh
what you're getting at here
um you know we have as the states
um we have granted uh the responsibility
for resource adequacy and the planning
around that to make sure we have the
generation we need in the region to ISO
New England
um and it is really uh their
responsibility to ensure uh that the
grid has the uh Power that it needs that
that our needs are being met I guess
what I'm trying to say is you know if we
see our population rising at a certain
rate that doesn't necessarily mean that
our electric generation capability has
to go up at the same rate right because
because other places may be declining
and therefore a little bit of their
power that they had in the past could
come our way
sure so system planning I think what
you're getting we may have less of a
need regionally over time and that could
happen depending on growth but we are
only roughly
to nine and ten percent of regional load
okay so we're a small piece of it all
right any more questions for
commissioner
our offshore wind if you could I went on
a
trip to Block Island to see their uh to
see their Terminals and I feel like our
region is pretty aggressively going
forward trying to develop that and I
know we have a commission on it I just
wondered if you could share some
thoughts on that sure
so I believe was in late 2019 uh
Governor sununu requested uh that boaum
the Bureau of ocean Energy Management
the federal government uh create
um
a task force for the Gulf of Maine an
offshore wind task force for the Gulf of
Maine
um uh that require request was granted
and we've been in that process with boem
boem determines the lease areas for
potential wind projects there's
considerable
um stakeholder Outreach as part of that
process and um you know in our
department we have a director of
offshore wind an office of offshore wind
development
um and we have a director in in that
position
um so what we're doing currently is
working through the Boeing process
um listening to stakeholders uh you know
as a state we've been promoting the
opportunities for companies involved in
the supply chain
uh for offshore wind that we are open
for business here and um we would like
to see those businesses locate in New
Hampshire
um other states Massachusetts
Connecticut Rhode Island have
procurement so they're they're actively
procuring offshore wind resources but
for us we're at a stage where we're
working through the Boeing process
um the lease Awards I believe uh will be
made in late 24 uh so so next year
um so things are moving forward Maine
has uh has received approval for
um a pilot project for offshore wind and
I believe utilizing uh floating
technology
um so that's where we're at we're in the
process we're carefully looking at uh
all of the options
um and and doing our due diligence
um as a state
just one more follow-up so
um we have a 10-year uh energy plan and
I'm assuming when you're deciding what
federal grants to apply for it relates
to the goals that are so are you
actively pursuing renewable energy
opportunities through the Federal grant
programs I mean you said something about
being energy neutral and I haven't read
the plan sure sure
um so
um we will absolutely take advantage and
pursue funding that that makes sense for
New Hampshire
um and um you know with a with a fuel
neutral all of the above position
um I could see us uh absolutely pursuing
funding for storage
um technology or or anything that would
make sense for New Hampshire
um I think we are open to all of those
opportunities
I think we should move on to the POC is
that who's next it is all right thank
you very much commissioner thank you and
do our clerks want to switch or
good morning chairman uh representative
I'm Dan goldner a PC chairman
um
here today to talk about the piece you
have a brief opening statement if you
like or yes go ahead yeah
so the Public Utilities Commission is
vested with General jurisdiction over
electric natural gas water and sewer
utilities as defined in RSA 3622
for issues such as rates quality of
service finance accounting and safety
with limited jurisdiction over
Telecommunications
it's the PC's mission to ensure the
customers of regulated utilities receive
safe adequate and reliable service at
very brief thank you Mr chairman So you
um in the budget and 363 and I noticed
on your handout that um you didn't
unlike others you did not include fiscal
year 2022 actual because maybe there's a
giant jump between actual and authorized
right a million dollars
okay
50 so what's going on there why why are
you authorized a lot more than you seem
to be using
um I believe it was mainly because of
the uh when the when the two
um when the two agents or when puc
um split split off some split off and
became Department of energy and OSI was
combined with
um that that part that split off that
there was some there were some funds
that weren't necessarily put in the
right buckets and um 23 the um the
commission and also the the department
of energy went to
um the governor and Council to do what
we call the reorg which was part of the
hb2 language when it created Department
of energy it gave us the opportunity to
go back to Governor Council and kind of
move things into the correct buckets I
think this is just a result of that
um
while while the two while the two um
agencies were getting their feet
um per se there was just um less less
spending there was a lot of vacancies
because there was a lot of the uh the
senior advisor positions were created
and they were and it took a while for
you guys to fill and there's one
actually still still unfilled so there
was a lot of vacancies so there was
there wasn't a lot of spending in in FY
22 the first year that the new
adjudicative Commissioners the puc part
and energy was created
so what you're saying is of the nine
unclassified positions only a handful
were there in 2022 but now you're more
staffed up is that
that's correct yeah okay
very good
all right now it says all of your funds
are other funds
are you taking some kind of from every
case you get a certain fee or how does
that work that's part of the assessment
the utility assessment so the department
of energy we're the ones that calculate
that assessment based on what is
approved in the budget and then um we we
send the assessment out to the utilities
um quarterly and then they pay us and
that Revenue gets collected into the
department and then based on the actual
expenses for the OCA and the puc we just
transfer the revenue over to them for
their actual expenses but the puc is 100
utility assessment
gotcha
all right
um
tell me more about
um specifically so we heard that your
your semi-judicial in in nature right
people people come to you and and say we
want so much per kilowatt hour and
somebody else says no
um is that the bulk of what you do or is
is there is that 50 is that
yeah I would say that's the bulk of what
we do so rate rate cases which are which
is what you're referring to and and the
follow-on to the to the large rate cases
so we'll have sort of interim there'll
be steps there'll be vegetation
management there'll be storm
um issues so we'll have some interim
issues as well but they're all related
to the rate case and the utilities
generally coming in for uh usually more
money and not less
okay and how often does a particular
utility come to you is it is a rate case
a year is it five years is it what is it
you know historically
um it's been I think the ever Source
rate cases might have been 10 years
apart something like that long before I
became chair but recently the trend is
more towards like a three or four year
Rhythm on the rate cases and again
they're sort of um there's issues that
come up in between rare cases that we
adjudicate but the the typical rate case
I would say is on a what's called a
three or four year rhythm
I see so so a special storm or something
like that could cause a slight increase
in rates it could yep there's um yes
there's a different different issues
that come up that they're they're all
adjudicated in the rate case so what
happens is that um that there's often a
settlement in the rate case and there's
an agreement
um from the parties that says that you
can come in if you're a utility you
can't come in for intermediate changes
uh for different reasons
um but that's adjudicated in the rate
case
how many different utilities do we have
and how does that change over time well
I should have brought a really good
slide I have on that topic but I'll I'll
answer the easy part first which is
there's three regulated Electric
utilities in the state in HEC is is more
or less not regulated by the puc there's
two Gas Utilities there's about 10 water
utilities and about half a dozen sewer
utilities that we regulate
we also have some regulation in in the
Telecom space which mostly takes place
in the form of poll transfers and we're
adjudicating a case there there right
now
having to do with eversource so you said
that New England the the co-op one is
not regulated yeah I would say uh
lightly regulated by the PC so we don't
have direct rate making Authority for
the for nhec
um we see them on some tangential issues
but not we're not direct direct rate
Regulators for an Etc I see yeah my town
is somehow on the edge of all this so we
have all three we have co-op we have
ever source and we have Unitil
amongst our in our town and there's
perhaps more coming this notion of
community aggregation which was passed
by the legislature we've seen a lot of
activity in that area we probably have
15 or 16 applications for Community
aggregation so local aggregation and
that's uh that's activity that we see
picking up quite a bit so that's yet
another Supply option for folks explain
that to me so the um the local community
so you know Keen for example can can
decide to
um can decide to purchase their own
electricity so instead of it being so
maybe you're a never Source customer and
eversource provides you something called
default service today so they they
provide you electricity at 20 cents a
kilowatt a hour or or whatever it is
over time
and that
that uh
that you have other options already so
you can go to a third party you can go
to the PC website it's actually the doe
website and look for third parties to
get perhaps a lower rate and now you can
get community aggregation where your
local community is purchasing power
supplying power into the uh into the
grid for those uh those local
communities themselves
hmm
so are they purchasing power
from some producer out of state or
something like that is that the they
can't we don't regulate where they get
it from you know electrons uh can go
wherever they want but um but often
they'll produce it themselves they might
have solar rays or some other sort of
local power that they're using they can
purchase it on the open market just like
eversource or Liberty or Unitil can and
so it's really a very new thing for New
Hampshire and the law just just passed
and we're just seeing applications now
but there are existing Community
aggregation
entities in Massachusetts and if I'm not
wrong Connecticut as well
very body or a Judiciary body it was I
was wondering to what extent uh policy
affects the decision making
the legal team can help me with the
legal vocabulary but quasi-judicial I
think is the term that they use if
you're an administrative branch agency
as opposed to a judicial branch agency
so we're we're quasi-judicial in that
sense and I'm sorry I missed the second
part of your question
I wondered to what extent policy affects
the decisions that you're you're making
um the the interesting thing in all this
that commissioner chicoine went through
was that in the new organization where
the PC is bifurcated from the doe is
that policy falls to the doe so that's
uh that's not something we engage in so
what we do is we're the Arbiters
so we look at the needs of the utilities
we don't want utilities to go out of
business because if they do then nobody
will get electricity gas and water so we
we want they need to stay in business
and also the needs of the rate payer on
the other side to make sure that they're
foreign
are your decisions
um
can they go to the Supreme Court if
someone's not happy Etc they can so we
have uh the process is that um in uh the
we issue a final ruling and um there's
an appeals process internal of the PC
but after the final ruling uh any party
can appeal to the the state supreme
court
has that ever happened yes okay yes
going back 100 100 plus years uh the the
puc has been appealed to the the state
supreme court I couldn't give you a
history of the outcomes but I think
there's a few
um
I can think of a couple that are active
in the state supreme court right now
okay
electricity or other
let me think one is uh what I'm thinking
of I believe are both gas is what what
occurs me at the moment we don't what
hap from a process perspective once it
leaves uh the PC and goes into state
supreme court it becomes a department of
justice issue so they'll bring us in if
they have any questions about the the
case or the docket or what have you but
we're not uh we're not really involved
once it goes to the Supreme Court that's
a department of justice issue okay and
so of your I assume it's the
unclassified employees who are making
these judgments yes
um or not necessarily I would um I would
I would say the judgments are fully uh
from the Commissioners the three
commissioners okay yeah so you sit like
a board and and you vote um that's right
yeah another the the senior advisors the
positions that uh that you're referring
to we are five filled and one open
um advises and we uh we have some really
really talented folks attorneys
economists and so forth that help us
understand the issues
um but the commission takes ownership of
the final decision the three
Commissioners gotcha all right thank you
very much any other questions
all right shall we go on to the
morning
hi my name is Andrew Diemer
okay
thank you for the opportunity to present
the fiscal year 2024 and fiscal year
2025 operating budget request from the
site evaluation committee the mission of
the SEC is the review approval
monitoring and enforcement of compliance
in the planning citing construction and
operation of energy facilities in the
state ideally our budget is funded
through fees paid during the permitting
process of new energy facilities this
mechanism however can prove unreliable
as it is tied to the number size and
scope of applicants currently there are
zero applicants
accordingly additional funding is often
needed to supplement the enforcement and
adjudication component of the
committee's purview
with me today is Lenny from Doe
director of the business office and
together we will endeavor to answer any
so you're the only employee that's
correct all right so what are you doing
to to find work right I mean find work
yeah yeah I mean what are you doing to
well as a state employee hopefully I
personally won't be finding work soon
but um no I meant
having something to do you said there's
nobody nobody kept me in yeah well most
of my time is spent on the investigation
side of complaints against current
generation facilities and uh as the only
member of the SEC it's
um I think it's enjoyable because I get
to learn how other agencies work I
always have to appropriate people
um often not willingly they're told that
they have to work with me the site
evaluation committee to process any
complaint has to appoint a subcommittee
of three people
the commissioners of multiple agencies
are on the SEC but they will usually
appoint a designee
to replace them so once we have a
subcommittee for a docket we will set
about the investigative phase which
usually includes a site visit usually
includes some sort of Investigation
in in recent history it's been Dot
uh conducting the investigation and
um
it's you know it's all going well it's a
long slow process but
we're we're handling the volume of work
that we have
so essentially your your administrative
is that what you're saying and that if
you if something came up you would
gather a board of decision makers to
deal with that particular problem that's
correct
um I
sort of run the blocking and tackling
any decisions that need to be made are
made first by a subcommittee and then
usually by the full SEC gotcha
all right when was the last time you had
a case or somebody wanted to be is this
mostly to build something new or not
necessarily you would hope but yeah
presently no I've been here since uh
late June of this year we've had zero
applicants for New Generation we have a
lot of people uh kind of pump faking me
telling me that something's coming down
the pike and then it hasn't come
um
I'm sorry what was the second party yeah
so so when was the last time somebody
built something new in in New Hampshire
do we know
man I'm trying to thank the last I mean
I I guess when Northern Pass was a big
deal there was a lot of stuff dealing
with your your area all right sure sure
but that never turned the last the last
thing that we actually permitted to
build and this would count as a new
application was the Seabrook nuclear
power plant applied to build a capacitor
Bank project on pre-existing land that
they owned adjacent to the power plant
so that was new
energy facility permitting it was just
pretty small
uh that was this year
representative thank you thank you for
being here to take the questions
um on that same line so if they existing
utility wish to build a new substation
for power would that be something that
goes through the process that would yes
and then follow up so they build the new
facility do you only examine the plan
for that facility or if they were
putting up new polls do you examine
every poll like what's the what's the
scope of we would also
um have purview of reciting the actual
transmission line
so
pretty much anything that's at utility
scale
so I'm looking at the budget here
360.
and there's some big jump
yes and I don't see where it comes from
FY 22 there was no administrator
um so you can see Zero for actual actual
spend on the uh the Personnel lines
there and then it was for 23 it was
budgeted as a vacant position which was
budgeted as step one so now in 24 25 the
position is filled at something other
than step one so that's why you see
those those jumps but work was still
going on the chairman the chairman of
the puc acts as the head of the SEC when
there's when there is no administrator
so what is the remuneration line
that's basically a word for other
expenses but what we pay out of there
um and you can see a little bit of
change from from past years we used to
pay some of the the work from the other
agencies out of there but we've moved
some of that those expenses to the
actual transfer to other agencies line
um class 49 but other things like some
some additional board expenses that
aren't aren't listed on here are paid
out of that line
um it's just kind of like a
miscellaneous type
and transfer to other agencies are you
getting new software or something like
that nope that's for um mainly for DOT
costs um or or any other agency that
helps with the um the citing process
that's a lot of those expenses removed
from the remuneration line to better uh
budget and have a little bit more
transparent
other questions yes representative
Cameron thank you Mr chair do you handle
complaints from citizens uh that uh for
proposed new projects or new new
construction and if so do they have to
pay any fees to uh to file a complaints
no I mean no they do not have to pay
fees to file complaints we do handle
complaints on new projects what
typically happens is we create a docket
for a new project and all the
information is posted on our website
um so the way that a complaint or a
public common as the case may be would
come to me is usually they would email
it to me it could also be physically
mailed
and then we post that on the website
and um depending on the volume
we will then email those to the
distribution list of all persons
interested in getting information so if
it was a major project like the Northern
Pass project and you were getting you
know maybe 50 you know letters or
complaints or something in a day then
you would probably bundle all 50 of
those together and you would send them
out and you would say here are the
complaints that came in on February 17th
or whatever but the way it works now is
there's so few and infrequent that
literally anything that comes out that
comes to me as a complaint or a comment
some are supportive as well
um is immediately sent out to the
distribution list and posted to the
website
um just curious our 5G towers are do you
deal with those because I imagine
there's a lot of complaints coming in on
that probably we do not deal with uh
solar I'm sorry um cellular
so this is agency income is that a
transfer from the energy Department
no that is the fees itself
fees on whom the fees on those that are
um you want to explain that we have a
fee uh schedule a fee worksheet that we
use and when you apply for a new project
there are fees based on um total
megawatt of generation the size
um there's a formula that takes
transmission lines into account just as
an example
there is a medium what I would call
probably a medium-sized solar project
that is still in the conceptual phase
and a medium-sized solar project
by my calculations to bring in about
sixty thousand dollars in fees up front
so it's not a massive amount of money
the northern pass on the other hand the
fees probably were and I could look them
up enormous sure you know based on the
physical size of the line and also the
uh generation what about the Seabrook
capacitors
it's a good question I do not have that
but I could certainly get you that
information it would have been a lot of
money
oh okay
and the problem that I wanted to add is
that you know from a budgetary
perspective is some years you it's feast
or famine you know right now it's famine
next year we could get a major uh
transmission or generation project and
we'd all all of a sudden be flush with
fees so um and they would lamps to the
general fund or do they roll over
they're continually appropriated
non-lapsing I see all right so it makes
his job I understand very fun and
interesting imagine representative evil
I'm trying to unwind you know you know
the different responsibilities now I
understand if there's a new site it's
very clear that you have authorization
to engage but aren't there or
there are situations where uh utility
polls are being replaced that are pretty
aggressive uh you know really widening
of the area that they pass through the
polls are much taller they cross
easements
um
I don't so I feel like the there's not
much oversight of those unless the
utility company comes in and asks you
whether it qualifies for some sort of
um I don't know judgment or or
assessment
um
and I just wondered if you could talk
about that a little bit because in in my
area there were several situations like
that that came up and um because it
didn't qualify as a new site I guess
there was no real oversight even though
a lot of people were affected so um
we're talking about transmission lines
correct really tall ones so
um when the initial certificate was
issued for the transmission line it gave
them parameters of what they were and
were not allowed to do so if an upgrade
was within the parameters of what the
original certificate said they could do
they probably would not apply for a
um for an upgrade now what happens more
often is that
when they um are upgrading a facility
they will uh file for what they
basically they basically want us to
declare whether or not it is a sizable
addition okay and this is not Apples to
Apples but in the in the Seabrook
capacitor Bank project for instance you
know they were creating something on
property that they already had so they
the ruling was on whether or not that
was a sizable
upgrade and the subcommittee determined
it was not a sizable enough upgrade to
require a new certificate so in the case
of a transmission line that was that was
being upgraded with really tall poles
um that would most likely require a
ruling from the site evaluation
committee that it is either not a
sizable upgrade or that it is a sizable
upgrade in which case they would need
but it's on the utility to request
is it not or do you I mean they have to
ask you whether you think it's a sizable
upgrade or if they just do it and you're
not aware of it then you don't actually
over they would have to ask us before
all right I think we want to get to the
consumer Advocate
um and but will it be interested to know
about the Seabrook payment how much it
was and when it came in
somewhere yeah 360. well it starts on
three
359 I guess
oh no it starts on 350 58.
foreign
all right thank you uh good morning my
name is Donald crease that is spelled
k-r-e-i-s I am the attorney who has the
honor of serving as New Hampshire's
consumer Advocate the office of the
consumer Advocate is an independent
state agency whose job pursuant to RSA
36328 is to advance the interests of the
state's residential utility customers
wherever those interests are at issue
the place where they tend to be the most
at issue of course is before the Public
Utilities Commission and so my office is
an automatic party to any puc proceeding
in which we enter an appearance and we
do tend to appear in all of the major
ones in respect to that I like to think
of us as helping the puc by Statute the
puc is tasked with the job of being the
Arbiter between the interests of the
utility shareholders and the utilities
customers and we put a little weight on
the scale on the side of the utility
customers because the utilities tend to
be very well represented and therefore
the shareholders interests are very well
represented as you've already heard from
commissioner shacoin we are
administratively attached to the
Department of energy they have a very
capable business office in particular Mr
Routier sitting next to me provides us
with lots of help but we are independent
of them I do not report to the
commissioner of energy I do not report
to the chairman of the Public Utilities
Commission
uh there are about 45 uh similarly
situated offices in jurisdictions around
the country we have a National
Association and quite a vibrant network
of ratepayer Advocates around the
country uh the other important thing
that we do
is uh we're very active regionally uh in
connection with ISO New England and
that's a very important part of our work
because with the deregulation of the
electric industry uh much of most of the
important decisions or at least many of
them get made at the iso New England
level ISO New England has a stakeholder
Advisory Board and I put the word
advisory in air quotes because it's
actually very powerful called nippule
and my office is a voting member of
nippule and the reason I'm highlighting
that today is that for the first time in
my seven years as consumer Advocate I
have asked the governor and now I'm
asking the general court to fund an
additional position on our staff so I
would like to grow the office of the
consumer Advocate from a team of five
employees to a team of six employees and
what I propose to do is to devote that
sixth employee to participating full
time in Regional electricity matters if
you look at the Nepal meeting schedule
on their website you'll see that that
tends to involve about eight to ten days
of meetings a month just to keep up with
all of their work and so my counterparts
in the region all have at least one
person who keeps an eye on Nepal and the
iso full time and I think that is
necessary for us to do as well our work
regionally complements the work of the
Department of energy
commissioner shacoin is the state's
Nesco manager Nesco is the New England
states committee on electricity that is
how the states appear in their
capacities as sovereigns at the regional
level and we participate as a member of
the end user sector meaning we represent
customers in the Nepal context and that
is an Ever more important part of our
work another big part of what we do is
education and Outreach
we get a lot of questions from
ratepayers and one of the things that I
think is most important about what I do
is I help make the puc process
accessible to individual customers or
groups of customers that want to
participate in puc proceedings and I try
my best to help them even when I'm
pretty sure that what they're going to
be arguing for is not something I will
necessarily agree with and I would like
to brag and say that we rolled out the
new website of our office on Valentine's
Day
and I urge you to check it out because
we designed it with those kinds of
imperatives in mind you know really
providing meaningful help to rate payers
who want to engage in that process
um
uh uh commissioner shacoin talked about
and I think chairman Golder mentioned
that you know we like every other state
agency group Face Staffing challenges
there was one wretched night recently
when I was literally the only employee
of my agency that was a lonely night
fortunately the next morning my new
legal assistance started but I I had
I've had to rebuild my whole agency and
I haven't finished yet I have filled all
but one of my available positions and
that is a been probably the most
daunting task I have faced over the last
year we are entirely funded by utility
assessment and you've already heard
testimony about what the utility
assessment is from my perspective it
means that we are paid for by rate
payers and I am very mindful of the fact
that with everything we do we are
spending rate payer money and we try our
best to deliver value for the ratepayers
um I I heard some interesting questions
earlier and I would like to offer a one
sentence take on some of those questions
representative hatch asked what happens
to firm pipeline capacity that isn't
needed and the answer is that there is a
it's a process called nomination excess
capacity is offered back into the market
so those who need extra gas can buy it
from those who have locked up firm
capacity the problem though is that on
those really super cold days of the
winter there isn't any excess capacity
and that means that because the gas
generators don't have firm capacity they
have trouble getting fuel and that
causes a lot of problems that that is
the most pressing problem when it comes
to reliability on the new the New
England electricity grid
um uh Mr chairman you asked about the
state as a growing Community relative to
other jurisdictions and I I think if you
look at the data you'll see that even
though New Hampshire is growing and has
a really healthy economy our electricity
consumption has actually been declining
and I have a two-word explanation for
why that is those two words are Energy
Efficiency from my standpoint as
consumer Advocate the most valuable
thing I can can deliver to the
constituents that my office serves is
Energy Efficiency and the answer the
reason is really simple negawatts within
n are cheaper than megawatts with an M
so I am an extremely outspoken and
energetic proponent of our state's
ratepayer funded Energy Efficiency
programs you can find them on the web by
just going to
nhsaves.com
and finally representative Ebel was
asking about offshore wind and uh I
would say that the Gulf of of Maine is
the Saudi Arabia of offshore wind but
from my perspective as the state's rate
payer Advocate it always comes down to
the fact that there's only one wallet in
the room and that wallet belongs to the
ratepayer so at least at the beginning
uh offshore wind power is going to be
relatively expensive and we have to
decide whether we're prepared to pay for
that as a community of electric
customers and of course we are going to
need to build some new transmission
capacity because the electrons that we
generate on those offshore wind turbines
aren't going to get to where they need
to be used without some transmission
capacity being added to the system
well I think that's all I have to say
that I thought of and of course I'd be
eager to answer any questions at the gym
so you're saying that even though we're
growing uh because of efficiency the
total use of electricity is declining
and therefore maybe we don't have to
worry so much about Vermont Yankee going
offline and some of these other kinds of
losses I I actually do think that we
need to worry about meeting future
demand more demand because I do expect
that Trend to reverse and the reason
that that trend is going to reverse is
that there are a raft of public policies
in place that are designed to Electrify
our economy rely Less on producing uh
heating things from natural gas and
other fossil fuels rely more on air
source heat pumps and very efficient
electric technology and of course it
looks like eventually we're all going to
be driving electric vehicles so no more
gas stations now you're going to plug
your car in so that's gonna that's gonna
reverse the trend and we are going to
meet we're going to need to be producing
and delivering more electricity to the
homes and businesses of the state for
sure
does ISO New England have a specific
plan that says electric vehicles this
therefore electric deals that therefore
you know every year we have to add so
much capacity Etc yes it does it's very
uh that if ISO New England were here
they would tell you that that is one of
their most important functions
okay and
but they don't themselves create
electricity right all so
our is the market is is is our companies
building new plans as we go along uh
there is new capacity being added to the
system it's very challenging because we
do confront constraints in terms of our
ability to bring more natural gas into
our region but there are other
technologies that we need to be looking
to we need to figure out how to bring
more electricity in from Canada so that
raises the prospect of something that
starts to look a lot like Northern Pass
there is the offshore wind challenge as
we heard about there are also all kinds
of opportunities to produce electricity
at the local level and we need to be
more Vigilant about bringing those to
bear on the grid
now on your budget I see
um there's an extra hundred thousand for
litigation
uh what do you use that for uh
so the word litigation I think has a uh
that's a budget word that is sort of
imposed on me but when we mean
litigation we mean puc proceedings so
it's nobody's suing anybody else it's
just the contested administrative
proceedings before the puc and you know
we think the puc is supposed to behave
like a court the the Quasi in
quasi-judicial means that I think they
do have some policy discretion in a way
that a judge wouldn't but it does they
are formal proceedings with a formerly
developed body of evidence and we
participate in that very actively
but are those funds how is that hiring
an attorney or to to be before the POC
or what is that no it really involves
hiring outside expert witnesses to
present a highly technical factual
testimony and opinion testimony to the
puc
the fact that it's go the fact that it's
going up by uh 40 or whatever it is
um no it's more than that it's
um you're expecting a lot more cases or
or those Witnesses are being becoming a
lot more expensive or what I I think Mr
radio can help you here but we've moved
some money around out of various
categories and tried to centralize all
of that uh or almost all of the money we
spend on outside Consultants into that
litigation budget line so I don't think
it's increasing significantly but I do
think that we need to uh we need to be
using more in the way of expert witness
resources that we hire from outside
Consultants so that's a fact
foreign
thank you for coming
um
when you're representing the consumer
with the puc or over issues that um
um are in their mind unjust or whatever
say the decision is still disputed and
maybe you would agree with that dispute
do you go with the consumer to a higher
court or what happens then
um or is it the end of the road so to
speak uh I believe that my statute
authorizes me to pursue any remedy
that's available and we do when
necessary file appeals before the New
Hampshire Supreme Court okay thank you
thank you Mr chair
people thank you
um one of the reasons I was asking
whether the puc was judicial or
quasi-judicial
um was that I had seen that the
commission had issued a report on Energy
Efficiency programs and that felt like a
policy position to me and I and
um I I've just confused about
overlapping responsibilities
well represented evil I'll say two
things about that one I share your
confusion and to the chairman of the
public utilities committee a commission
is sitting right behind me and my job is
to win favor with the puc and not
antagonize it and so I really would
prefer to answer that address that
question in pleadings that I expect to
thank you
so when the commissioner Coyne said that
um
his Department was one side of a PUK POC
case do you really mean you or are you
yet another person in the room
uh well we are a pre-existing condition
uh in that the office of the consumer
Advocate has existed in some form or
another since 1978 and I've always
thought of us as the principal source of
weight on the other side of the scale in
order to understand the emerging role of
the Department of energy you have to
kind of look at the history and see that
really the the department of energy is
regulatory support division is what used
to be the staff of the puc so the puc
had its own team of analysts and experts
and they were they were there to advise
the commission and help build the record
and my job is to actually Advocate and
try to present things that are really
from a ratepayer perspective and I think
those two perspectives are very
different so so commissioner shacoin and
his team represent essentially the the
executive branch of state government and
I do not I'm a completely independent
official all I care about is residential
rate payers interestingly if you look at
the state of Vermont right next door in
Vermont those two functions are under
the same agency their Department of
Public Service I I think our Paradigm is
better
it's brand new yeah they the department
of energy is brand new only about a year
and a half yeah so there's still uh not
to speak for the Department of energy
but they're they're still uh in their
adolescence I guess and they're still
sort of figuring out how best to
function and it's interesting and fun to
watch them develop as an agency and we
have a good relationship with them now
does your office deal with anything
other than electricity yes we're active
in all of the industries that the puc
regulates so natural gas is of great
importance to us uh commissioner goldner
mentioned the fact that there are a
couple of natural gas appeals we have
actively appeared in one of them and the
oral argument was just the other day
very interesting issue and water is a
very big deal because while we could
live without natural gas and electricity
water is essential to human life and in
those parts of the states where the
state where there are water utilities
that's very important and and people
care about that I've noticed that when
there is an active water rate case
that's when I get the most phone calls
hmm
other questions
okay thank you very much thank you any
homework for these guys no okay all
right so we're gonna move on to
the Community Development Finance
Authority and maybe we can stand up for
foreign
um
and this toward the middle of the page
and then a little bit onto 164. so the
what's interesting so let's why don't
all right and thank you for coming so
what's really interesting is your letter
says I'm going to be administering 21
million dollars but what's in the budget
is
uh 250 000 so
and there's no people in it you don't
even work for your your group here so so
excuse me hold on a second
163.
yes sorry go ahead
absolutely
um thank you for the opportunity to
address you and regarding the one line
that we do have in the State Treasury
Department's budget for fiscal year 24
and 25 which is New Hampshire's required
match for the administration of the
federal program the Community
Development block grants which is better
known as cdbg and administered by the
Community Development Finance Authority
so we're a state chartered independent
non-profit organization our board is
nominated by the executive Council and
the governor and approved there for as a
state Authority we're among a handful of
unique organizations that work in
partnership with state and federal
entities to deliver a cost-effective
program for the State of New Hampshire
I'm here to request the continued match
funding from the state of New Hampshire
the request is 260 000 in state fiscal
year 24 and 280 000 in state fiscal year
2025. this represents the federally
required match of State funds towards
the program administration of the
Community Development block grant
program
this increase from prior budgets request
meets the the minimum State match will
enable cdfa to best meet the needs of
New Hampshire communities cdfa will
increase technical assistance and
training provided to those leveraging
these Federal resources as well as cover
other increased costs associated with
program Administration the fact the last
three years have really Illustrated to
us the need for communities to receive
technical assistance to understand how
to use these Community Development block
grants we've also seen and I will
illustrate in a few minutes the real
importance of the block grants as a
foundational investment that allows
communities to really consider and
Advance really important Community
Economic Development goals so this is
often the funds that meet those basic
human needs in a community and when a
community is able to really meet the
needs of people they're able then to
continue to think about how to make
investments in the community
revitalizing downtowns really fast
during Partnerships that allow Child
Care Facilities to be built building
housing those things that are
foundational to Economic Development
Across the state
for nearly 20 years cdfa has provided
the state with an exceptionally cost
effective system for administering the
cdbg resources the cdbg program is pro
is focused on developing vibrant
sustainable and Equitable communities by
providing decent housing suitable living
environments and expanded economic
opportunities principally for people of
low and moderate income
we focus on the on administering a
program that creates the greatest
possible Community Driven at impacts and
adapts to the needs of New Hampshire
communities
cdfa has awarded more than 180 million
dollars in cdbg resources since 2003.
these critical resources have been
deployed across the state and had have
made significant impacts in economic
development in the handout that I
provided to you there's some of the
numbers that that show the impacts that
were made just last year on the first
page of the longer handout and they show
that we've that in just last year the
program assisted nearly 16 000 people
through Public Services those are things
like
um access to nutritional food Child Care
Facility uh how the household that
receives child care facilities in a
facility that was supported by cdbg
funds invested public in public
facilities and retained uh or created 76
jobs rehabilitated or preserved over 600
housing units we were recently speaking
on a project that were invested in right
now in Salem two projects actually very
different projects one is an investment
of the block grant programs to actually
create new affordable housing in Salem
and the other investment is actually in
an existing Manufacturing Housing
Cooperative that without the investment
of the block grants would be closed down
because the electrical conditions the
condition of the electrical
infrastructure is so poor that it was
really
critical to the health and safety of the
residents there that that be improved so
the block grants were actually able to
be leveraged along with utility funds to
improve the electric infrastructure
throughout the park at Friendship Drive
so just two examples in one Community
really different circumstances but where
the block grants were leveraged into
that Community to make an impactful
results for local residents
the result resulting support will ensure
that New Hampshire communities continue
to have access to these millions of
dollars of federal resources that are
meeting the critical needs to economic
success in our state These funds are
really aligned with a number of
strategies that the state of New
Hampshire has developed and that we are
part of advancing including the office
the Department of Business and economic
Affairs and their retention and
recruitment strategy as well as the
Council on housing stability strategic
plan for housing
New Hampshire's cdbg program prioritize
investments in areas that support these
strategies including the development of
affordable housing expansion of
affordable quality Child Care Facilities
you have an example of that in your
handout at the Mid-State Health the
Mid-State health is a federally
qualified Health Center in Plymouth they
had been operating a facility in the
basement of a church for around a dozen
students and they recognized in their
Community through a planning Grant
actually through the block grants that
there was a there was a deficit of about
300 Slots of child care and so Mid-State
Health decided to take advantage of a
building that that was vacant purchase
that building using the block grants
they were actually able to expand that
to 60 60 families that Center opened
this spring as in and is in operation in
addition to the 60 families that have
access to child care they also increase
the employment so they increased Quality
Employment and as a federally qualified
Health Center they were able to hire
child care workers and ensure that they
had benefits and livable wages in their
field
cdbg projects in New Hampshire like that
the project at Mid-State Health they
leveraged millions of dollars of
additional investment into our
communities
I'll just speak a little bit about the
City of Laconia and some work that we've
done there I imagine that that many
people know about Laconia and um and we
highlight Community progress indicators
so these are information about every
community and we use this information to
really understand the conditions of
what's happening there and to be able to
assist municipalities and thinking
through how they could put together a
block Grant application that's where we
spend a lot of that technical assistance
so Laconia is the most populous
municipality in Belknap County as I'm
sure you all know it has the highest
rates of snap which are the food stamps
as well as the free and reduced price
lunch those are two of the indicators
that we collect we collect 13 indicators
on all 206 230 form municipalities
across the state really giving us that
snap snapshot and idea of what's
happening in communities
across Belknap County families spend 27
percent more than the Benchmark of 30 of
their household income on housing so
housing costs in Laconia are really high
and more than eight percent don't have
health insurance household income is
statistically lower than the state
median income
which along with the snap in the school
meals enrollment can be a good indicator
of how people in Laconia are faring
financially
so cdfa uses these indicators and other
information to engage municipalities on
projects that could be meaningful in
their community and over the last decade
we've made significant Investments to
help this community meet basic human
needs
a couple of examples of our investment
include the facility improvements at the
Boys and Girls Club of Laconia allowing
that building to be a former church that
was vacated and was empty for a number
of years to be
um used by the the Boys and Girls Club
to provide that service
assisting the Lakes Region Mental Health
Center in consolidating in its
facilities into one central location
being able to provide then better
services to the residents of the area
and also to improve the efficiency of
their operation
renovating the Cornerstone downtown arts
and culture venues like the Colonial
Theater and the Belknap Mill although
not done with the block grants the
engagement with the block grants allows
us to then use other community Economic
Development tools and to make those
investments in the community
so it's unfortunate our representative
from Laconia is missing today
um let me ask you some Financial stuff
so I would I would guess that this 200
and this 540
000 is half of your administrative costs
would that be right that's about right
okay
now
um it says here that in 2022
um you made grants of 19.8 million but
on the front of the page it says you
expect for two years to make grants of
21 million so is the program getting
much smaller or is something going on
there no no we administer other funds as
well so this is a this is a suite of
programs that cdfa and administers
including a state credit program some
other Grant and loan programs as well
all focused on community Economic
Development so the block grants are
about 10 million dollars of our total 20
million dollars invested each year
okay so we're only involved in the 10
million dollar part yeah and and there's
something else going on I see gotcha
okay
yes uh representative Campbell's
followed by representative Sweeney thank
you Mr chair so through your data
analysis you seek out communities that
may need may need help uh or does it
work the other way do communities come
to you because they're aware of this
department yeah so it's both
um the programs are all open and
accessible to all municipalities so each
municipality in New Hampshire could
access as much as 1.5 million dollars a
year
um and communities know about the block
grant so when they have a project that
really serves low and moderate income
people they seek us out we provide them
technical assistance and support for
working through an application and also
being competitive in the competitive
Grant programs which are twice a year
thank you and um you say the communities
know about these programs uh in what way
how do they know is their advertising or
is it just a common thing that all all
uh these communities know yeah so we
work on um annual advertising we work
with Partners like the New Hampshire
Municipal Association the center for
non-profits
um and really ensure that all
communities have information and access
about the program we also gather
statistics on who's applied and who
hasn't applied particularly
um if they haven't applied we really do
that Outreach to ensure that they know
about the program we know Municipal
staff have so many things that they're
really handling
particularly over the last three years
and so we're trying to provide that
Hands-On technical assistance so that
they can access the program
the other thing that it provides is
actually Grant administrative support so
we work with both private Grant
administrators and the regional planning
commissions to be sure that communities
don't have to take the burden of
applying and then administering the
funds on themselves but they have the
support of Grant administrators
yep
thank you Mr chairman are we as a state
accessing the maximum amount of grant
money available for us are we leaving
money on the table under this umbrella
yeah so with this uh with the
recommendation and approval of these
funds we would be accessing the entire
amount available to the state of New
Hampshire in a follow-up question you
had mentioned using statistics for a
community for median household income
whatnot
um obviously projects going on in my
district in Salem we have wealthy
neighborhoods and we have low-income
neighborhoods that kind of skew our
average cities like Nashua Manchester
are the same position so when you're
assisting communities applying for these
federal grants what is the language
utilized to the federal like don't look
at the one towns you know average income
or whatnot how are you do you go down to
the neighborhood level like census block
or what's the what's how do you how do
you factor that yeah so we look at
community to be wide information and we
also look at census information as well
New Hampshire gets its allocation based
on a federal
federal allocation formula so it's
overarching it's actually for the State
of New Hampshire and its income and and
population that determine the amount
that the that HUD provides to the state
of New Hampshire for the program but
then as we're understanding what the
needs are in any given Community we're
looking more granular particularly in
those larger communities that have
really differences amongst
neighborhoods or areas
yep
and in the Salem example I think is a
really good we're both looking at
existing conditions so what's the
conditions in a community
um that really need improving so is it a
public health uh like the mental health
center whose facilities aren't adequate
we're looking to improve existing
facilities but then also to be building
new as well
representative evil
here so I have a couple of questions so
the the amount of the match that's
Illustrated here when the block grants
are made to the municipalities or
whomever
have you already provided the match or
do they have to provide more match money
to get a grant or how does that work
yeah so they do not have any required
match so a community could actually
apply for the funds and it could be the
the total amount to cover the cost of
the project a community doesn't have to
match the administrative cost that's
done by the state and then we generate
revenue from other activities to
complement and the additional
administrative needs of the program
right and then I had one other question
so I'm more familiar with the New
Hampshire Housing Authority so they get
involved in housing as well so what are
those sort of lines of funds some that
you have and some that they have yeah
absolutely so they administer a couple
of funds that are also administered by
the Department of Housing and Urban
Development including the home program
and also the Housing Trust Fund cdfa is
actually similar in governance to New
Hampshire housing but we focus on
Community Development so while we do
invest in new housing construction we
are often the sole funder in things like
housing Rehabilitation also Child Care
Municipal Water and Sewer that allows
for housing to be built so there's a a
different
focus of the block grant funds but we do
sometimes partner on projects the
project in Salem that we had spoken on
and used as an example it has
significant funds from New Hampshire
sure housing and then the block grants
well so you mentioned child care now a
couple of times and of course that's a
big issue in the state of New Hampshire
I mean as the grants come in are you
prioritizing needs of the state or
absolutely yep so Child Care is a high
priority in our prioritization of
applications okay
and we do um a process annually of
really evaluating the data of the most
needs and getting public input and using
so in general this is a competitive
situation right you get a some number of
Grants and you figure out the best X
that meets the amount of funds you have
yes yes as opposed to
you take everybody who qualifies and and
divide up the funds so some they might
get 60 percent of what they would need
or something like that right it's the
former so it's a competitive grant
program and those that align most with
the priorities the state of the projects
that are funded we also provide planning
grants so to ensure that projects are
ready for the implementation part of the
guidance and assistance that the
authority provides is to to provide
planning grants without which allow a
project to be ready for that
implementation
So when you say Child Care does that
mean you're giving grants to private day
care centers and things like that or you
have to be non-profit
and they have to be primarily serving
low and modern income households so 51
of the households served by the
non-profit facility need to be
um need to be low in moderate income so
they have to already exist they don't
actually
um they don't have to already exist and
we have done some new facilities
um but they have to be non-profit owned
and serving low and moderate income
families those are the priority well but
they wouldn't know who they're serving
until they start serving yeah so we
often in that case encourage them to
come in for a planning Grant to do a
market study because we do want to
ensure that there's the families that
need the care
um that are going to be eventually using
the program but we found that
considering the information around the
care gaps in New Hampshire that that's
not ever been a problem
really great for these sorts of Grants
yeah across our program so we administer
the state tax credit program so the
Community Development tax credit program
which is an allocation of five million
dollars of state tax Authority each year
that's provided to similar Community
Development projects we also
competitively apply for grants that the
state would otherwise not be able to
complete an application for recently a
small business administration Grant to
support very small businesses which are
the majority of businesses in New
Hampshire
um and so across all of our programs we
probably see about double the
applications for the funds then we have
funds available
yeah representative hatch thank you Mr
chair and thank you and thank you for
the very good work you do it's um been a
real benefit for my area in many many
cases
um but my question is um the unutilized
black grants that often can happen
um
you alluded to it somewhat but how hard
do you work to uh assure that everybody
knows that this is available and what
its utilization what it can be utilized
for
um because again I've seen more than
several times where the funds were
unutilized but there was certainly a lot
of needs that needed to be met so just
how do you address that I guess yeah
thank you so if any funds are ever
unutilized um they're not they don't
we've never returned funds to the
federal government so we uh
re-re-reauthorize them into a new
project but we do recognize that there's
a significant amount of needed Municipal
capacity to carry out these important
projects so that's part of what we
really look to provide is support to the
municipality so they can complete the
application and then meet the federal
requirements that are necessary to
utilizing the funds
um we have had some challenges during
covid with projects but we've actually
had no failed project so we've had to
provide additional technical assistance
really ensuring that they are successful
at doing the competitive bid process and
finding contractors and completing the
work we've had to have a few extensions
to ensure that the work can be completed
but it's all been done within the time
frame required of the federal funds and
those projects to date have all been
successful so it is
um we really do look to your point to be
sure that particularly communities with
very limited staff can access this
resource because communities across New
Hampshire need it
mm-hmm
thank you very much for coming thank you
so being a few minutes after one o'clock
we'll open the work session
and look forward to the Department of
and again commissioner if you could
state your name for the record and I see
you brought your able assistant with you
good morning Mr chair our good afternoon
Mr chair uh members of the committee um
my name is Dennis Goulet and I'm the
commissioner for the Department of
Information Technology and with me is
the Deputy Commissioner Ken Dunn and
behind me is our finance director Rose
Curry
sort of publicly thanked them both for
all the hard work they've done on the
budget
the I'm gonna
all right you see I brought a hefty
presentation don't worry I'm not reading
all the words I'll take you through it
in a summarized fashion and
um it looks like we have a an hour
budget and so feel free to you know stop
me and question me on any in anything
but I'll take you through this fairly
rapidly
um it's great to be here I think this is
my fourth
um test testimony budget work session
before Division One Finance and and
fifth it'll be my fifth um uh budget
that I've done since I've been with the
state as the commissioner of doit
um the department of Information
Technology is a heavily centralized
organization uh you know Pro maybe the
most in the country and you might ask
yourself well why does that matter I'll
get into that a little bit later but one
of the things that helps us do is we
really do know a lot about what's going
on in I.T in the executive branch and it
helps us on the coordination and and
driving efficiencies and things like
that and we'll show you some examples of
that as we go forward through the the
presentation our responsibilities and
Authority are outlined in the RSA 21r
there are a couple uh requested changes
to that built into this presentation
which I'll hit on when we when we get to
them moving on to page two
um also want to point out we do have a
strategic plan that's posted publicly
online is available and and in fact uh
rep able as a member of the information
Technology Council helped us with that
um I won't go into any detail but it is
available if the link is in the document
which we did share with uh with Melissa
I believe and and available also if you
Google uh New Hampshire doit uh you'll
find that right away uh call out the
Strategic themes a couple of the uh more
important ones that we you know some of
the stuff I would call like hygiene of
course we want to you know have strong
Partnerships with the agencies and all
of our constituents and of course
performance and effective Resource
Management you should expect that of all
the organizations in the state and we we
take that pretty seriously but in terms
of you know key initiatives This Modern
digital government and cyber security
are pretty big we're spending a lot of
Cycles on that and and
it's driving a lot of what we do today
moving on to page three
without going into the detailed words
um covet really changed the way we
operated and we haven't changed back and
there's a couple key areas one was we
had already our strategic plan had
already called for enterprise we used to
call it Enterprise partnership now we
call it strategic partnership and really
what that meant was if there was an
opportunity to use the same solution
across multiple agencies or even all
agencies we should be doing that rather
than buying the same thing here and here
and here and here and you know not
getting economies at scale and
potentially running them differently and
less effectively so so we had already
started that through our previous
strategic plan turned out to be really
really helpful when covid hit because we
had things in place that that really
allowed us to turn things around quickly
another thing that and so we're going to
continue that
um going into this biennium and we'll
take you through a little more detail on
that another thing that it did is it
accelerated the pace of everything we do
and everybody was saying okay well now
it's time to slow down you know covert
is over or whenever we were saying that
but we haven't
and it's two things one is that we just
got used to moving more quickly uh I
think our work our teams got accustomed
to
um being able to make decisions and
Implement more quickly and had
confidence in the in themselves to do so
so it was really a two-fold thing
um so you'll see that
um you know continue focus on Enterprise
partnership and Enterprise Technologies
to drive Effectiveness in in the
executive branch of government
and of course we'd I'd be remiss not to
talk about cyber security
we uh starting right before covert we we
initiated a comprehensive cyber risk
assessment for the executive branch and
we learned a bunch of things there we
found some strengths and weaknesses and
we we worked to address those weaknesses
and um and so in many ways
we came out of uh the other side of
covet stronger on the cyber security
side but
our enemies keep getting smarter and
more effective and changing the way they
operate so moving on to Paige the next
page just to summarize all those those
paragraphs you know we have to keep we
have to keep adapting we have to keep
investing
to stay ahead of all the threats that
are out there and that's one of the
things that we spend a lot of time on in
the we have a cyber security section for
each Information Technology council
meeting and uh and it's a big focus of
ours to make sure that we're transparent
on what we're doing and and we're also
adapting to what the threat threat
landscape is out there so
so moving on
um to page five at the top
um
we build this budget over a period of a
year or so working collaboratively with
our agency partners so the way we're
organized is we have we have a division
that focuses on agencies and we'll talk
more about that as we get into the into
the presentation but for each agency
there's an I.T lead and that I.T lead
collaborates with the folks inside the
agency to develop their budget and so we
at the same time we developed there what
is called an aitp an agency Information
Technology plan and so we use those
aitps every every biennial budget cycle
to help align with their budgets in
other words okay so here's your aitp
here's what you say is important from a
technology perspective for your agency
and here's what your budget says and we
hope that the budget aligns with what
they're saying is important to them and
try to steer it in that direction so
it's kind of a very high level overview
of how we how we build the the it budget
particularly the age agency direct I.T
budget
there's there's some budget Trends
you're going to see that the the areas
of the budget have gone up quite a bit
and and I thought it would be important
to explain what the trends are that
we're seeing that are driving some of
that the first and most important is
agencies continue to invest that
technology density I call it inside the
agencies is increasing they're using it
more
um and and they're asking for more in
each biennial cycle that we've gone
through so and we'll talk some more
about that as we get into the the bones
of the of the budget proposal
but it really is and and there's so
we're also seeing that in some cases
they're moving stuff that was in their
budget into our budget so like dot did
that for the last budget cycle they had
a whole bunch of I.T stuff that actually
wasn't in our budget that got moved into
our budget so it looked like the spend
went up but it really didn't
uh overall
agencies are also asking for increasing
resources
thank you I'm I'm I got to leave very
shortly so I'm going to jump to the end
and interrupt you
um so your budget ends on page
um 56
that's where the big totals are it's
very similar to page six of your
presentation correct except that
includes
2022 actuals
so there's a big jump between uh 2020 to
actual and 2023 authorized about almost
20 million dollars
so are you going to spend more like 2022
or more like
well we always we always have a
significant underspend in the in the um
salaries and benefits space because we
we're always historically we operated uh
you know around a nine or ten percent
vacancy rate right now we actually have
uh a little over I think it's a little
over 12 percent vacancy rate so it's
actually Low by uh the state standards
some of our my agency partners have much
higher vacancy rates but that that means
you know that that salary and benefit
line we're going to understand and and
agencies you know we do understand
um at the agency level for some of the
agencies and and also in our shared as
well based on uh particularly if if
things are based on PC counts and you
know we're billing based on PC accounts
and there's less
um there's actually less less employees
than we plan for because we plan for
authorized
so if there's fewer than authorized then
you know we may be could have found any
understanding yeah so but a 10 vacancy
that would be a 10 million dollar thing
or even less right this is a 20 million
dollar thing right so yeah yeah so we we
will We historically do understand what
our budget is by a significant
significant amount and and so and then
you're expecting an an extra 16 million
from 23 authorized to 24. maybe some of
that is what you said
um D.O.T is adding and some of these
kind of things right you know yeah in
fact I have that a page for that in this
presentation if you'd like to jump to it
I want to make sure you get what you
need when you take off so um sure yeah
let me let me find out what page that is
here uh all right uh let's go to page
eight if you would
in our presentation we'll talk about the
uh
the the largest
chunk of that increases agency Direct
agency direct part of the budget is the
part that's large almost completely
driven by agency business priorities in
other words we they tell us what they
want we do it and that's not people
that's things and you can see kind of a
general list of the types of things that
are purchased on that and and the ask
from the agencies
compared to 23 adjusted authorized
versus what the ask is for 24 and 25 you
can see it's a you know it's a 30 almost
31 percent increase in the requests that
we've got from the agencies
so to the extent that they actually
spent spend that then we would be in at
you know at a 62 million run rate
agencies do typically
underspend that line not all of them
though um
it you know really depends on whether
they actually have the ability to
execute or in some cases like we look at
uh priorities change in the middle of
the biennium and they do something
different than what they were planning
on doing that uses their resources and
they don't end up doing the I.T project
so it's it really there's no one thing I
could point to that says that is the
lever that gets pulled that says they're
either going to use all their I.T
um direct it's budget or not but we do
so that's so that's more software
licenses and more Hardware but it
doesn't really take more people to spend
that it does it does in fact because I
don't see any people counts changing
right well um so in in uh it's if we if
we go towards the end of the
presentation uh
see I feel further down I'll take you to
page
15.
these are positions that were requested
in our initial submission
that that
were not published or not approved in in
the governor's budget but the agencies
had asked for it's a mix
the all but the very top line of that
I'll jump to I'll skip mine and jump to
the liquor commissions for extra two
extra heads they uh 70s that were
submitted for to help them with their
next gen project
safety had asked for two and these the
ones that aren't 70s are are currently
sitting as unfunded positions in my
budget
um so dos asked for two Revenue asked
for two and your revenues logic there
was um rather than hiring Consultants
from there from the fast systems who
runs their revenue information system
they wanted to fund state employees
which is actually less expensive
then there's
the area of of
I.T leads fish and game and Veterans
Home don't have an IET lead so they
agreed to share one in their direct
budgets and um and so and so
and so um we're gonna we're actually
asking for all these positions get put
in the agencies themselves have have
authorized the spend inside their their
budget obviously you need to authorize
it but but
um and I think a lot of these are
actually division one
um
um agencies as well so the top one is
the Chief privacy officer function for
the state what we're seeing now there's
I think there's over 20 States now that
have a Chief privacy officer and
New Hampshire has a pretty mature cyber
security program and so like if you were
to come ask me what are you doing about
this cyber security thing and do you
have a consistent policy and approach
across all executive branch agencies I'd
be able to say yes very definitively but
on the Privacy side I would not
um I I you know I think that our privacy
we don't have a privacy function in in
the state government for the executive
branch and uh I think it's becoming more
and more important I'm seeing
legislation coming up I'm seeing
questions coming and I think you know I
think it would at this time it would be
wise for the state to invest in in this
function and this function is really two
ftes it's a it the way I Envision it
it's an appointed
it's an unclassified Chief privacy
officer who who has to go through the
nomination and GNC approval process so
there's that transparency to who gets
placed in in the position and then
there's kind of a policy administrative
support individual there
um so anyways I would I would
I definitely would like to fund that
that's not something the agencies ask
for it's something that I'm asking for
and based on what I've observed going on
both in terms of the legisl our
legislations that's coming up around
privacy as well as things we're hearing
from the public things like that so
so those are the people that are being
asked for
so be a little more clear about what's
the distinction between security and
privacy sure sure um so cyber security
really is about
protecting protecting from the
unauthorized access to data or the or
the ability to take down systems by
virtue of ransoming and things like that
so it's it's basically
stopping bad things from happening
privacy is the the discipline and the
function of determining how information
is going to be managed inside the
organization
so who get who has access to it how when
if at all that kind of stuff so it's
it gets confused a lot but it really is
very different and stay and like I said
the um the 20 plus states that have what
they call a CPO Chief privacy officer
have a a chief information security
officer and they had a Chief privacy
officer as well
so so you mean like just because I'm
Commissioner of dra I can't look up what
your taxes are or something like that
exactly and also I mean it's really
getting kind of important like you're
seeing particularly in Europe right
Europe was the leader on that but you
see it now a lot of times where
um there's a shift in the world from
entities a lot of times corporate
entities or other entities who are using
data in a way that you didn't
necessarily know about as an individual
or authorized that's kind of the heart
and soul of what the Privacy function is
is all right how do we interact with our
citizens and businesses in the state
with respect to
how we're whether they're authorizing
our use of their data and how and how
that relates to all the different pushes
and shoves for example in some cases the
federal government requires us to do
things to access funds that we wouldn't
necessarily do on our own account for
example you know so it's mean it's it's
kind of a complex Art and Science all by
itself
so carrying on a little bit from
representative McGuire's questions I
wish we still had Lynn over here because
as you recall maybe Lynn's watching saw
a little wave there but
every year we see a
pretty significant climb in your
requests if I recall and it was always a
concern of those of us that have been
here a long time that at some point that
should start going down I mean those of
us that run smaller businesses or you
have your own home system you buy a
laptop it lasts for a couple of years
you don't have that continual expense
and I'm looking
where you cost your agency is all other
funds but those other funds can in fact
be General funds say from Corrections or
some other agency so what you do even
though there are other funds we have to
look at the general fund impact now I'm
looking at
like the Department of Health and Human
Services on page eight
and of course most of that's Federal
funding but that's a significant amount
of money 31 million dollars for 24 32
million dollars for 25 and I'm just
curious if you could put something
together for maybe the last six years on
what the request for just those
particular agencies that you have this
the top seven agencies
because it just seems we never go
backwards you know I did see one thing
in parentheses in red here somewhere but
we continually climb and I understand
that uh you only went to about 90
million dollars and spend last year but
you're looking at about 125 million
uh for 25 it's a lot of money and again
people will use the argument with us
that well it's just other funds but it
really is there's a lot of General funds
in there
oh it is in fact Rose can you remember
what about what percentage are our total
General funds is that like 40 cents 47
running around
46.7 yeah so you can kind of assume that
whatever is approved what do we actually
spend about a little under 50 of that
will be General funds and the rest will
be for other other you know so the color
of money is determined at the agency
level yeah but but we've we calculate
back particularly for uh Governor's
offices always asking us that as he's
developing the budget to know what
impacts are having a general fund
impacts uh certain decisions would would
have
uh representative evil followed by
representative Griffin
um thanks for being here commissioner so
I remember especially the Health and
Human Services I.T budget from the
capital budget side was always massive
and a lot of the reason for that is that
there were requirements for the federal
government in order to process payments
and all that kind of stuff so
is more of what I was used to seeing in
the capital budget now in the operating
budget or and how much of this is
required as you know like it's not
really optional whether you do it or not
HHS has a challenge right now in that
they have quite a few pretty old systems
so I think a lot of what we're seeing
there and in fact I'm going over to
division three with um
with the HHS folks next Friday to talk
about because division three breaks it
up so I'll be there for the I.T part of
it
uh well MMI uh mmis is one of the big
systems yeah so the so HHS has two of
the three largest systems in in the
state the three biggies are New
Hampshire first which is our Statewide
Erp system
integrated eligibility which is also
called New Heights New Hampshire easy
and and the Medicaid system it's called
mmis so those are the three biggies so
two out of three of the big three of the
three biggies
all right HHS plus they have a bunch of
other systems and a lot of those are
transitioning
from older technology right now to newer
stuff and adding features to to
um
to to mitigate the fact that they're you
know that they're having Staffing
challenges like everybody else so yeah
uh I you know off the top of my head I
couldn't tell you exactly where that
stands but but I if you know one of the
things that if it might be interesting
to uh listen in on the division three
um hearing on next Friday because uh
that'll I'm sure representative Edwards
will go deep into that
for that question
well it's it's actually more of a
comment what we saw in the capital
budget is we ended up spending so much
on I.T it actually acted to you know let
the leaking roofs uh continue to leak
and and as I said part of it was that
some of these system upgrades were
really being required by the feds they
did match but you still had to do it so
yeah they're massive 10 of a lot of
money is still a lot of money so whether
it's a 90 10 match or a 70 30 or
whatever that yeah so indeed in fact and
and
um
and there are a lot of
you know we do see a lot of additional
requests both on the capital side and on
the operating expense side through DHHS
for it stuff and there's not a single
thing I look at those projects and
there's not a single thing on there
though like oh we shouldn't be doing
that it's all good stuff and that and we
we never
um you know on the capital side they
never get all the stuff they ask for
fund it so
representative Griffin well
so all of that leads
into my question I think
um this morning
you spoke about uh the number of
applications and I think there's like
600 applications and we talked about one
specific
application that was 14 years old and
needed to be replaced
is there a way
to reduce the number of applications or
are they likely to grow
and secondly
what is the uh typical
lifespan of an application okay well the
my desire is to reduce the number of
applications and that relates directly
to the Enterprise approach so if I have
a an and HHS is doing the same thing so
historically what they did is they
implemented by division inside HHS and
now what we're trying to do is look
across HHS and say all right we should
have one case management system the
services all are different you know
basically I call them lines of business
but they call them programs and so we're
working on so today if there's let's say
you know a half a dozen case management
systems
uh the strategy at HHS now is to move
those all to a single platform so we
would go down from say six or eight to
one
the other thing is is and it didn't
really come out and I felt bad about it
today at fiscal it didn't come out that
generally speaking we're not coming to
look for a fiscal transfer for to do a
to do a an upgrade we're generally
trying to budget it there's certainly
upgrades in in the HHS budget and the
other agency budgets or you might see it
in a capital budget like for example uh
Revenue did there replace their 30 plus
year old system with a with a capital
appropriation now this the question on
how long systems last
practically speaking you should get you
know you're investing a lot of money to
implement a new system
and the shorter time it lives
the you know the you know the more
expensive per year it is actually to run
it if you amortize that out right so I
would think at least we should get at
least 10 years out of a system and and
then you know at a certain point you you
hit a diminishing curve where the the
you know technology has improved to the
point where you could do a lot better if
you replaced it but you still have to
invest so that's the challenge of this
the software life cycle that I spoke
about at fiscal this morning is you know
where's that line and and then you may
hit that line and still not get funding
to replace it for example labor
department has a long-standing LBI audit
finding that you know they've been
running a really really old 30 year old
system and
which is true but they went for a long
time without actually getting funding to
replace it so there's that challenge as
well sometimes now there's a new Factor
that's come into play which is the the
software as a service cloud computing
we don't know what that's going to do to
software life cycle you know it and it
in in software life cycle may be driven
by a new set of factors it's fairly new
particularly for the state so we don't
you know a preponderance of our
application portfolio is still running
in our data centers now but what we're
seeing is as new applications are being
procured by agencies we're seeing them
being deployed as Cloud applications in
the in generally in the you know
government clouds which are you know
protected from a security perspective
and
and what's that going to mean for life
cycle what's going to drive changing in
the future because the software is a
service
they they manage their own life cycle
inside their product you're buying a
subscription so it might be more
performance of the vendor or things like
that maybe the driver in the future
versus oh this is just really old and I
need to replace it but we don't know
because it's we're fairly new on to that
game and that's going to be one of the
things where we're we're thinking about
as we go forward and planning is a whole
bunch of new things that we're learning
how to do as it relates both on the kind
of the infrastructure side as well as on
the application side as it relates to
managing in the cloud environment versus
the old you know in my data center
foreign
thank you that helps helps clarify the
situation but if I do the math and you
have 600 applications and
you get a 10-year life cycle it's about
60 applications a year you have to deal
with that's pretty intense
yes and and we we almost never have an
app that lasts only 10 years
I might in the private sector I might do
that and you know if you look at a
private sector comparison you you might
capitalize a implementation and then
depreciate it over a period of seven or
ten years whatever you thought the life
cycle was once that was done you know
you you may have the financial impetus
to go do it again and state government
we're you know we're operating leaner
than that and so 10 years would be
unusual to see it happen that much it's
more I'd say the average is probably
more like between 15 and 20.
foreign
I also remember from from uh from Public
Works we used to talk about these
massive investments in I.T and that
it would take two or three years to
actually make the purchase
be effective and to be installed and all
do you do you work that into a concept
into your operating budget or you go for
the Big Kahuna and then
um do you know what I'm trying to say
yes exactly well the new implementations
the big new ones are often uh Capital
Appropriations and so we're looking at
usually a two to three year
implementation plan and then we and then
it goes in what I call
capex to Opex so you so so it's
legitimate
it's it's legitimate to fund you know
say licenses during the implementation
phase with capital but it isn't once
you're running it because that's really
truly an operating expense so kind of be
improper to do it with capital at that
point so where it might get wacky is if
you were ahead of schedule and you were
running and you were using capital for
that or on the other side if you were
late
and um you know you're and you know you
you have you don't have capital and you
move into an operating expense mode but
you actually aren't live yet so that's
kind of the push and shove on how new
applications get funded replacing an app
is even in more complex because you say
you've got a run rate expense for let's
call it application a
that
um and then now you application a is 30
years old and you you need to replace it
so now you're going to replace it with
application B well you're going to spend
and it's going to take you like uh
Revenue took three years to get theirs
done right and they actually did it
really fast compared to other states and
so during that time you have all the
expense of application a for whatever
your implementation period is plus the
additional expense for implementing
application B then and and the revenue
again did a great job with this as soon
as you're live on application B you want
to cut out that application a expense
but you're double dipping for that
entire time
so not only like going back to the
fiscal committee discussion this morning
on Erp if you know Not only would a new
implementation be considerably more
expensive than than migrating to the
latest but also we'd be double dipping
that whole time
so it's fun you actually application I.T
people have to be really good Finance
people so it turns out like being a geek
represent Camp rails do you have any
questions so far all right so we'll
continue through your presentation all
right well there's one page that's all
right this is your this is your meeting
so you should take it where you want to
go
um so going back to page
um the drivers I just wanted to make
sure because a lot of what you were
hitting on was were these things it's
page five
um
and we did get you know so we hit the
first two already pretty well
um
the and I and we just talked about the
what I call the capex to Opex shifting
from one time so it may not be as
expensive in other words if you say uh
I spent 10 million dollars on to
implement something and it's going to
cost me 1.2 million a year then then
you're going to pick up that 1.2 million
you know once you go live in in the next
biennium so we see a lot of that
um
there's been a change in the market as
well our our vendors who sell to us are
shifting from this
buy it
give me a lot of money to buy it and
then
give me a modest amount to maintain it
and then every six or seven years I'll
make you buy it again
very bumpy Revenue curve for them right
so so what they're doing now is they're
offering subscriptions instead so it's
not a purchase maintenance model anymore
it's a subscription model so it's not
bumpy from a revenue perspective
but for us on any one year that might in
as we shift from a capital intensive
approach
to implementing and paying for systems
to to an operating expense approach it
increases the operating expense even
though average cost over say a 10 or 20
year period is probably similar
so so that's a factor we're seeing now
happening big inflation in
uh Hardware software services
and the late and outside contract labor
as well to help Implement them big
increase
and then shorter equipment life cycles
what's happening is
the security and compliance world is
driving our vendors to
to to a shorter life cycle now I think
part of that cynical because they said
all right you know if you want to stay
compliant you have to buy something new
and instead of every seven or eight
years now it's every five or six years
so that you know kind of adds to the yes
but we must stay compliant because we
get audited continuously uh well we we
must stay compliant because it's the
right thing to do from a cyber security
perspective but also we do get audited
continuously and um you know both on the
from our federal Partners as well as the
payment card industry and our liquor
business is the largest
um payment card um
Revenue producer in the state and I
think DMV is the second largest buy but
they're not even close Liquor's way
I feel like the The Liquor Commission
just recently upgraded all its credit
card systems but I feel like there was a
budget request that had to do with
upgrading that again or replacing it or
is my memory well believe it or not they
did it seems like they just did but
it actually was a while yeah I guess
I've been around yeah yeah no I I have
the same thing because we just did their
networks over in all their stores again
I'm like didn't we just do that I'm like
yeah it it and we're getting better at
doing Liquors there's so many stores and
and have you have to have a system to
get it all done so we're getting a
little better at doing that but
all right so moving on page six is kind
of important you've seen the the you
know in your budget book you've seen a
lot of these numbers but
um I want to take you through some of
the how it works these different
accounting units because it's important
they're all very different in some
pretty important ways the first one is
direct and again I mentioned this before
direct is largely driven by agency
priorities in other words we put in
there what they tell us to put in there
and unless it's ridiculous or they don't
need it but for the most part what
they're asking for aligns with their
Agency information technology plans and
and makes sense at least from an
operational perspective
so that's the biggest part of the
increase the the next one the 7703
shared sir we call it shared services
that iDrive that's called that's what I
call Hygiene that's the stuff that has
to be there but you don't get any credit
for
um you know and everybody uses that and
we allocated out based on a formula and
we'll go into that more detail later in
the presentation
salaries and benefits
is pretty large as you see
and that is roughly 50 50. in other
words half of those are supporting
shared stuff and are being allocated out
according to a formula the other half is
direct and is being billed directly
salaries and benefits to agencies
and so you saw those those additional
head count asks that the agencies were
requesting earlier in the presentation
those are those are the direct part
those would be billed directly and those
are at the request of the agencies
uh
I'm looking at the governor's approved
budget requests that were
talking about then I'm looking in the
document that we have and then the
numbers don't line up I
what you have is 129 million for 24.
That's not including talk talk oh yeah
it's Telecom
is added so if you look at just the
without Telecom it's 123 or you know the
Telecom is 6.145 that's a that's a
different
a different uh accounting unit okay
so yeah I audited it back when the after
his presentation the other day I ran
back to my office and made sure the
numbers total numbers matched because I
was with something we worry about
so that the total numbers do match I
think what you're looking at doesn't
include Telecom okay
which is a nice segue because I just
went over salaries of benefits Statewide
Telecom Communications is a is a
non-lapsing fund
um
or dedicated fund that supports the core
Network and and all the phones
for executive branch and so the way we
operate that's a little different
there's staff and um and equipment
that gets funded in that we over collect
over a period of about five years and
then we re-buy stuff without
asking for Capital Appropriations
so that's a nice
it's a nice transparent way to run an
I.T business because we're actually
collecting what it actually costs to run
the business versus Under collecting
and then coming to you for a capital
appropriation to replace stuff
it's a relatively small part of our
budget as you see we'd love to have it
be a bigger part because it's
you know as I said I think it's it's it
represents that shift to an operating
expense mode that our vendors are
pushing on us and so we're doing that
ourselves and and so that works out
pretty well so the core network is
funded in that the core executive branch
Network which is a pretty big Network
it's fairly expensive to replace I don't
have to come
ask you you know I don't have to ask you
for additional Appropriations for that I
don't have to ask for Capital
Appropriations to do that we do that out
of our regular operating the last time
we went before the Joint Committee for
dedicated funds we were able to show
that we were not over collecting we were
in fact it was amazing how close to what
we were collecting and what we were
actually needed to run the business was
so I know it's always a concern of over
collecting or having a slush fund but
so what you said it's a dedicated fund
what is the source because I heard that
they want to repeal the communications
attack or is that oh no no that's better
what's that's doing I think that's
funding some of the um
some of the 911 operations and things
like that oh okay yeah I think that
flows into I I could be wrong because
it's not my area of expertise but
um okay that's something different
what this is is basically what we do is
we say we calculate what does it cost to
put a phone on somebody's desk
and that's what we Bill them per month
what does it cost with a phone plus
voicemail and and we have a rate card
for that in fact we didn't bring it with
us but we can share right right now in
fact a we're charging uh what's the VoIP
so a basic telephone
um a basic telephone line that most
people have is
that's a purchase and where's the uh
where's the monthly charge
yeah about 32 dollars a month that's
what we're charging for to put a phone
on somebody's desk but we've got a rate
card and we set that rate card every
reset it every biennium
it's that's what drives the actual
budget
and for what and we also all of the wide
area network is in that so we have
almost 400 connections back to the
Mothership so our main data centers at
27 Hazen drive and we have almost 400
connections back there that support all
kinds of things anything from dot sheds
to uh to uh you know HHS district
offices or the unemployment you know
nhes employment security has their their
offices so you add all of that up and
it's almost 400 connections the way we
do that is we take cost plus 10 and
that's what we build and the 10 percent
the that extra helps pay for the staff
the 10 people 10 or 11 people that we
so that's kind of the the chunks of our
budget and how they are how they kind of
fit together the second table down there
is just showing the percent increases
it's really the same numbers
um page seven is a breakdown by glass
line so you can really see what the blue
highlighted is where all the big
increases are and this is the total doit
budget
it's a total of all of those accounting
and so you can see it's Hardware
software and Consultants are the big the
question do you think we save in the
number of employees we need because of
all the I.T that we have are there any
savings
it's hard to say well what I can tell
what I can tell you is there's no way we
could run the business a lot of these
businesses with the same amount of staff
if they didn't have the technology
so
yeah
in fact there was there you know I I've
heard discussions about oh you know we
should what if we just got rid of these
systems wouldn't that save money well no
because then you'd have to run that
business manually
and you know we we're seeing other areas
where I know that we're investing in
where
um
an agency is having trouble keeping up
with their work and we're trying to find
solutions for technology that would help
get it done with the same amount of
people because they're having trouble
recruiting
so that's a that's a Focus right now too
because of the job market and the labor
market and trying to you know the
difficulty of recruiting particularly
well kind of a follow-up
um to representative Evil's question
have you ever figured out how many uh
seats you've vacated through technology
I have not you have not been kind of
interesting it's interesting because we
don't talk generally talk about that
um you know when I was in my whole
private sector career that was the deal
right if you were a department
and you wanted X millions of dollars to
implement a new system
part of what the c financial officer
would say all right well
what are you going to give me you know
and then that is you know we don't link
we don't link employees back to projects
because this isn't how the state
operates
representative cambrell's yes thank you
Mr chair I I noticed on the one of the
page where you showed uh the additional
bodies that are being requested I think
totaled six or seven
um upon the budget you go from 370 to
372 so that's an increase of two
um
what what's the real number of employees
yes
good afternoon Rose Curry Director of
Finance for doit in the budget process
we had 470s that were presented those
are new positions in the 24-25 budget as
we went through the governor's phase
they did not approve those positions but
when they disapproved them for two of
the positions they reduced the dollar
amount but the position count was not
updated so as we went through the
process at the end of the year we'll
figure out and come to we'll reconcile
the position count but the official
count is 374 DOI take okay follow up and
um
currently what is your your vacancy rate
uh how many open positions do you have
that are not filled uh 12 12 percent
thank you you're welcome which is about
between two between two and three
percent up from the norm pre-covered so
we're actually not doing horrible knock
on wood even though it does that extra
two or three percent does hurt but it's
you know I'm hearing 20 from some of my
peers so I'm feeling better about where
the consultant cost would they be what
they are
you had all the employees you need or is
that just it's amazing to me when you
get new software you always need to have
Consultants not you one yes
um the the challenge with recruiting and
the Staffing levels
um particularly in the agencies does
drive a lot of use of Consultants
and we're seeing more of it in fact we
have a staff augmentation contract with
administrative Services has a staff
augmentation contract for technical type
people and we're the Run rate of usage
on that is is higher than ever right now
and it's driven by
you know that the inability to recruit
particularly certain skill sets in the
tech Arena
there's wage inflation and Tech has gone
crazy
and so recruiting certain skill sets and
they happen to be the ones that all the
new systems use
are are pretty difficult to recruit in
so going to positions again and
following up and maybe representative
cambrell's comments on page 12 you list
authorized positions of
370 at the top
unfunded 14.
so is the governor's Budget on funding
14 of these 370 positions or no that's
just what we we historically carry
unfunded positions and so that's how
many we carrying in the in the
okay
I don't remember where I was here uh
let's see
so I think you know I think I'm going to
skip some pages because we really
already went through a lot of the
details of
eight
nine
and
10 uh what's 11. you saw that's the one
negative number in there
Mr chair and that's simply structural I
yeah
um that's that I think that's structural
but one less pay period in in that year
which is what drove that because
typically that goes up structurally
because of Step increases and things
um there is
um
speaking of positions on page 11 at the
bottom there's some requested House Bill
um but the
two two budget Cycles ago I removed we
we requested division one remove the
designations for our divisions because
we were in the process of kind of
reassessing our skill sets and our
organization
having completed that we have names now
for the divisions and
we thought it important to get those
names into statute so all this is doing
is essentially taking
putting back the names that we removed a
couple budget Cycles ago but with the
actual names as they are now versus the
old names that we removed so that's the
essence of the requested hb2 language at
that doesn't change any salaries or
anything like that by
it it does not all all it does is put in
in statute what we're actually doing now
okay
I guess uh for the LBA something to add
to our hb2 list thanks yes we got we've
got a full list and and I don't think
um
so you on page 12 we've already been
there and you can see one of the things
I like to point out in the table at the
bottom of page 12 and you can see the
names on the org chart you see the old
names that were in statute a couple
years ago and then the new names that
were requesting be placed in statute
under that hb2 language
also one things we like to look at is I
always I always fear you know throughout
my history that you know we have become
two top heavy as an organization and I
always watch for that so
um when I look at this I say okay that's
pretty good because we've got you know
60 percent of our um
60 of our spend is is unclassified those
are the people that are out there
getting the work done and you look at
your your your
unclassified some pretty small percent
the Senior Management of the of the
organization so I just wanted to call
that out because we're I think we're
running
fairly reasonable proportion there not
not super top heavy
a telecommunication we already talked
about but there is a budget footnote
that we all that's been in in the budget
for as long as I have been around at
least and
what that essentially does is allow us
to
expand excess funds beyond the
appropriated funds
for that once in a while big thing that
I described before so like if you recall
I pointed out that this for this
dedicated fund we over collect and every
once in a while we'll have a large Buy
that's beyond the appropriation of what
we're collecting during any in uh
biennial budget and that goes to the
and the other the other checking balance
there obviously is the Joint Committee
for dedicated funds where we do
reporting on it whenever that that
okay so in the page 14 is a summary of
all the um
the hb2 requests
um
the first one again has been in statute
I think for
um
two budget Cycles now essentially what
this allows us to do is I'll give you
the prime example somebody retires
we don't think we need that position
anymore but we need a different one
rather than waiting an entire budget
cycle we we unfund the retired position
and fund
one of the unfunded positions so we
don't add positions
and then we hire somebody into the role
that we need so that allows this
language allows us to do so it doesn't
allow us to overspend our appropriation
and allows us to operate considerably
more effectively inside any biennial
budget
so I would request that that continue to
be placed
in in house bill 2. um the the next one
we already spoke about which is the
actual the naming of the divisions
inside doit and the last one is um
our Information Technology Council is in
statute the membership is
without going into detail it's in 21r
but the membership is agency heads
um out you know education outside
business
um
County government city government and
two reps
and so we thought that it might be good
to have two more additional reps on the
council for two reasons one is we have
trouble scheduling and getting more than
one rep at any one meeting I'd I'd like
to have more exposure and transparency
to the house
through the I.T Council so it'd be great
to have two or three reps at any one
meeting
and and just generally more transparency
I find that you know having uh
representatives there and participating
in the development of our strategic
plans and our cyber security strategy
all of that stuff is helpful to us and
it's helpful to you so you can kind of
know what we're doing and not feel like
we're out there um you're running a muck
so
um that one is important to me I'm not
sure that the the speaker would want to
do it because there's a lot of you know
assignments that have to be done but I'd
love to have four reps on the executive
on the it Council if I could
all those divisions all about
transparency as we've witnessed so far
this
term
um so the three requests I guess we can
anyone have any issues with those
collectively
the yes I mean I already mentioned this
to the to the commissioner I just know
the speaker isn't wild for these
councils anyway and I'm I'm
I'd be I don't know
I'd be cautious about that just because
I'm not so sure what the feeling would
be so
I mean it's obviously our recommendation
but
yeah we're under orders to cut out a lot
of these commissions and things like
that when did you ever fall award well
okay
um no heartburn either way on that one
um
so the we're back at the the last couple
of pages here which is um
the um the head count asks all of them
except the Chief privacy officers were
were motivated by agency requests and
and the agencies were willing to um
to spend that money and you know
prioritize that spend inside their
budgets and we after the governor
published his budget we went back to the
agencies and spoke to each one of them
again and made sure that they wanted us
to ask for this and I know some of them
already have
I think revenue for example may have I
don't know for Evan has been before you
yet but no they haven't
but they've been before us for just a
presentation but not a budget
presentation but while we're on these
agencies I noticed representative
Edwards on House Bill 5 19. I guess is
requesting the Chief privacy officer is
that their Chief Financial Security
Officer for the Department of
Information Technology so is it Chief
Information Security Officer yeah yes
well
so jive with so uh that actually
um
I already have so again what that
legislation and and that resulted from a
phone call one day on a weekend from rep
Edwards he's like hey you know he had he
had had a whole bunch of cyber security
questions for me and I answered them to
his satisfaction and then he said well
what do you need from me and I said well
I have a chief information security
officer but it's not in statute so this
that that request from rep Edwards had
no fiscal note because it didn't need
one because I already have that position
established it's already been it's
filled and it's been filled for over a
decade and it's and its salary is set by
the jcec so it's a done deal so it's
simply uh I call it legislative
for exec yeah yeah
I'll review okay well it doesn't cost
anything and it all it does is establish
the role in statute which is you know my
role is already established so it's it's
just consistent with some of the other
stuff we're doing and and it's really
important because
cyber security is a big deal so I want
to make sure that that whoever the
individual is I'm on my third Chief
information security officer in uh
almost eight years I've been here so
it's
it's a it's important that whoever comes
in knows what their responsibility and
Authority is if another you know if
somebody decides to Triple their salary
and leave leave the state you know again
so
um
there's a couple other things in uh on
the last page flip over page 16 that our
agencies had requested in the governor's
budget didn't get funded and they wanted
to have and I think liquor already may
have spoken to you about
their their two head count that they
asked for the 270s as well as some of
this other stuff that was on page
16 they would like that put put into
their budget and then Lottery had a
system that is really important to to
them that they wanted to ask us we
confirmed again with both liquor and
Lottery that they wanted this stuff and
um so I'm just asking that that be
placed back in their their direct
budgets
and and then the the very last thing are
we we
froze our budget for the governor and
then we had last minute requests coming
in from agencies so these two bullets
are housekeeping type requests that came
in
to us after we had closed the governor's
budget and they didn't have time to put
them in
so
um so that's all that is those last two
and I think one of them's already being
one of them's already being dealt with
so
and um that concludes our uh our
official
uh testimony uh attachment a which you
have is the details associated with all
that actually would go into the specific
agency budgets and not you orders both
actually because the what happens is
they end up in their class 27 line and
then they end up in our detail lines so
they're in both places that's why it's
really important it's confusing
it requires coordination and if you look
in the budget you'll see there's acts so
basically it gets double counted and
then there's a place down low somewhere
in the budget where the double count is
so I have to compare I'm just looking at
the additional prioritized needs for
liquor which you had identified here and
there's definitely a lot of things not
lining up
um
so we'll have to look at that a little
more yeah I'll give you the I was done
before I was going to comment because
liquor did send us what they asked for
and it didn't look like what we had so
no I would agree different I would agree
with you like they were asking for more
money correct I think it's into the
millions of dollars
but it may not be the same thing so yeah
we if you want what we'll do is we'll
take the action of going back to Tina
and Joe
and reconcile that and get that back to
you ASAP
yeah we'll we'll make a copy of this for
you and make sure we get the numbers
eight there was some confusion with
their numbers as well so we'd ask them
for some additional information so we'll
get you this we were scrambling with
liquor a little bit because their their
testimony was pretty quick and after the
after the governor had released his
budget and and so we we we probably
caused some of that confusion just
because we were trying to do it quickly
yeah they're uh I.T wants here are much
more substantial than what you are
showing so it's yeah some of that may
not be in our class 27 too because
liquor has stuff that they spend on
store operations that isn't always in
our class 27 budget you might be in one
all right well I'll give you this and
other further questions for
the commissioner and the deputy or
second table what maybe some of the
really big drivers are of the 30 and 20
almost 25 percent increases are there
I'm not sure you have them yeah but
they're pretty eye-popping and we might
have to
explain them as we get into it well the
we do have the drivers for the 25 and
that's on page
the the 30 is a little more complicated
because it's agency by agency but we can
get we can get that well I mean there
may be some really no we we can
definitely do that but I would say I I
the answer to your question on as it
relates to the shared service portion is
at the bottom of page 10. okay and um it
it's three different areas it's the you
know inflation of
Hardware cost it's the
the Enterprise the the Microsoft 365
costs which are everybody who's running
Microsoft 365 in the world is seeing
increases there both in terms of how
much of it we're using as well as they
had a price increase for their for their
um
for their platform and then
we're spending uh contract money a
little above what we had historically
done to support the um some of our
projects that we're working on and
that's that's actually a great example
um
back filling staff that we don't have
you're welcome we'll get you that other
thank you much have a good weekend
thanks for your great work there
[Music]
we could have made it without you guys
foreign
on page
whatever page we were on with the
additional requests uh page 16 16.
there's an item from
for lottery
that division two was ready to approve
but we usually coordinate between the
divisions and the LBA analysts to make
sure that both divisions are in
agreement
on that one
and the word that they heard yesterday
from the lottery was that it wouldn't
impact any Revenue to the education
trust fund
so
so your recommendation is we I would put
a check mark there if division two is
happy and they've been
um assured that there's no Revenue
impact than it
it's probably good to go everybody good
with that
yes
yeah although there's some overlap like
with oit and you'll see as we go further
along you probably remember from last
there are a lot of things that
overlap and
so it's kind of confusing and that's why
we have people like the treasurer here
to help us out
so nice to see you madam treasure if you
come forward and
I'm sure you have a handout you're
so 164 everybody if you're looking
foreign
so good afternoon Mr chairman and
members of the committee for the records
the treasurer Monica mazzapelli and I'll
be using the handout just to facilitate
the um the discussion and then the
references that I included in the
handout
um I hope I'm using the right document
is is the actual um Governor's budget
document that was posted on the
um Department administrative services
website I'm still trying to orient
so I will start with
um just a brief overview of our agency
the State Treasury and the first the
second page of the handout which is I'm
as you know we are responsible for um
we're us we're a central uh Service
Agency responsible for processing
um our cash and debt management
um
business of the state and um in
as part of um as part of what we do we
have our offices structure and and if
there are essentially two divisions but
um this budget is proposing one change
in terms of the structure and I'm also
using another section of our office to
really highlight a piece that has not
been highlighted in the budget which is
the college savings scholarship program
so if we move to uh page three it's just
I'm describing
um again the areas that our office is
focusing on and that are now part of the
budget so
um for the first time we are split in
what we call our trashy operation
treasury operations and it's now where
we as part of our agency budget we
requested to split that office into and
create the office of investment and debt
management the office of debt management
is actually established in RSA 6B but it
was never really clarified in the Statue
so we decided to do that because a year
ago we prepare a three-year strategic
plan and as part of you know the the
goals and and what we were discussing as
part of our what we want to see over
time and the treasury
um we realized that the um the sum of
the roles and responsibilities needed to
be clarified so this is a little bit of
housekeeping internal housekeeping to be
able to um
again be in compliance with the Statue
attract expenditures and the budget in a
better way provide transparency and and
also clarify some of those roles and
responsibilities of some positions that
will help us with succession planning
and and all sorts of goals that we have
so
um so that's a difference you will see
that
um difference in this budget compared to
previous budgets
we also have our random property
division this the division responsible
for the claim property program and the
stay we return property that gets
reported to us and remitted to us and we
report that we return that to a rightful
owner
and again
um the the last piece that we highlight
as part of our office is our College
savings scholarship program so we've had
this program so sometimes but now we
have a position that is supporting
um you know in addition to treasure and
the deputy Treasurer who did the work
before now we have a specific position
that supports those programs who are
which are very um they take a lot of
time in our office so we're trying to
again just clarify those roles and and
all of this is in our budget so
um so page four is just um
right now we have 23 positions this body
is actually abolishing one it position
and it will go down to 22 positions and
this this this this this or chart the
only minor changes
um this section that relates to
investment and debt management uh we
just again move some positions to define
those roles and responsibilities so it's
a minor change but it's important to our
department
um so on page three um you take
questions during your presence
absolutely anytime Mr chairman are there
any questions
I do have one nobody else does
so you just mentioned that you're
eliminating an I.T and I see that you're
migrating to our state doit is that
going to save you money or is it going
to cost you money to
I would assume you're going to save some
money because you're eliminating a
position but I'm just curious of the
cost difference
yes no that's a great question that was
going to be my next point so yes so as
part of yeah so as part of what we're
proposing a diff a difference in this
budget as we we would like to migrate to
doit so the state treasury the T the T
component of the treasury was always
in-house and we had two positions in the
past supporting the entire operation and
it was just a sign that way since the
very beginning of time and as you heard
from commissioner Goulet cyber security
is a big deal it's really important and
we've had the I.T position that we want
to abolish we've had a vacant for some
time and it has been practically
impossible to fill it and so the
decision is we want to grow our tea
Department which is essentially
impossible or we want to just you know
move with doit and the rest of the group
and again as you heard the work that
commissioner Goulet is doing it's all
about protecting the state it's all
about you making ensure our
infrastructure is safe and so to me it
was a no-brainer to request this change
the governor approved that and I just
hope is is you know continuous with this
but so the the answer to your question
is yes we're gonna save some money
abolishing the position it's gonna the
the general fund portion is gonna
increase slightly compared to what we've
been paying because
um we still have one it person that will
coordinate the work between the treasury
and and the uit and but this person has
done an amazing job to protect our
treasury to protect our bank accounts to
keep our costs down but that's about to
change slightly if we move with the rest
of the group which again is is all to
benefit the treasury and the benefit the
state as a whole to be protected
um you know one of the things that
made me think about that that decision
was the fact that Duit was receiving all
this Federal funding and and you know
support from legislature and the
governor and unfortunately as a little
house you know it house we weren't
getting anything so this didn't feel
right
um so that's part of the reason so
there'll be a slight increase but I
think overall obviously after that you
won't see any changes but um it will be
part of what the uit requests every year
um so that's that's so that's the second
change in this in this request in this
budget
um
again minor things but um important to
us
um and um again
we do have a question
please thank you Mr chair well in the
interest of efficiency wouldn't the
employee that's working for you in IIT
move over to doit or wouldn't they want
to hire him since he has a lot of
knowledge
and and I'm and I'm they did ask that
the unfortunately the funding for that
position is with the abandoned property
so abandoned property base for that so
changing the funding mix
um didn't seem appropriate because
unless unless you want to play that
position with General funds so then we
want to keep that position with us to um
again to facilitate all of that there's
some pieces that so so the request today
is to migrate essential I.T
components not everything so for example
this I.T person uh who's going to stay
with us will will still coordinate and
manage other other systems that we have
for example for the unclaimed property
program we deal with a vendor and he's
the person responsible and and that
works with our vendor and to to support
the unclaimed property system the same
with our banks you know we use
um online banking and all of that is
overseen by this person the uit doesn't
want to get involved in online banking
and in all of this other systems so
we're just getting basic services from
doit
thank you Mr chairman so moving on to
page five it's just again um with the
creation of this office of investment
and debt management is really a new
activity code that we're creating and so
we moved all our debt service under that
um activity code
um so speaking about that service on
page five
um we are
um
that is really our largest well in
addition to meals and rooms tax
distribution this is our largest
expenditure so the treasury expenditures
you know the for the Department of
Treasury are very small is about two to
three percent of our total budget The
Debt Service
um is another large portion but
obviously that's for the entire state so
we we we house uh our debt service The
Debt Service that we pay and
um our outstanding debt continues to
decline but our debt service so and so
in this particular budget we are in
order to budget and estimate what our
debt service is going to be so in
addition to our existing that service we
are assuming that we will issue 60
million in 60 million in bonds each year
and that's what um and that's the debt
um so we also um I guess one comment I
want to add is
um
the The Debt Service the principal and
interest of the bonds that help pay for
the Rems project from the for the
revenue information management system
project that dra has
um now that that service by law I needed
to um be paid beginning in fiscal year
22 from this a dedicated fund that they
created they established uh called the
revenue information management system
account so in beginning of first year 22
that that service is being paid from
that fund so be 422 that was paid with
General funds now is being paid with
this dedicated fund we try to ask dra to
put that that service line in their
budget unfortunately with all the
discussions and we tried again with the
governor's budget but that didn't happen
I'm hoping that can happen and during
the house phase but if not we just we
will deal with that it's really just the
location of what that service line
um just like all of the agencies that
have there are self-funded they pay
there on that service we typically see
that that service line and their budget
right now it's sitting in our budget as
older Revenue so it really makes more
sense to move it to dra but again it's a
tactical thing that perhaps we could fix
in the future there's not enough to time
or
um because tra will have to add it to
their budget
could you get an explanation to us I was
very good but something in writing that
to the LBA we can take a look at that
absolutely absolutely represent Maguire
thank you Mr chairman so am I right that
the total State debt is somewhere not
including unfunded pension is something
like 1.2 billion
yes for our Geo bonds uh actually for
all of our bonds revenue bonds and and
general obligation bonds I think
including turn by include intern
practice oh let's start a stop yes could
we get a is there a list in here about
which areas are in have debt and like
that Turnpike is so much and you know
UNH is so much and I can certainly get
that for you as is not included in this
in this presentation the presentation so
what we house in our budget we pay
general fund um
we we include so our budget includes
Geo Debt Service
that is paid with General funds it is so
it also includes a portion that we pay
for the University system of New
Hampshire also what um we what the
school building ate that service and the
community college debt service
so those are the components all of the
other Debt Service as in the individual
agency budget so for example fishing
game has their own Debt Service
in Turnpike highway so the only ones
that we keep here and the treasury are
general fund funded with General funds
and those that I just mentioned and
they're really because they don't really
have a house anywhere else they end up
with us
um could I continue yeah thank you so
the 60 million we're paying
this is interest and principle yes
that's correct okay on so it's on a
fraction of that 1.2 billion is that
what you're saying that is what I'm
saying yes okay so do you know how much
roughly or is it
so this is the annual Debt Service
um
that is scheduled to be paid or
projected to be paid in fiscal 24 and
25.
so that relates that number relates to
just the general fund portion of the
state so it total that's so out of the
total outstanding of the 1 billion that
you mentioned only about
500 and close to 600 million
belongs to a general fund just get that
number
okay
so that's that's the general fund piece
and that's the piece that we um
in our when when
um when we asked for a recommendation of
how much should be bonded typically we
we mentioned about 120 million for the
biennium so 60 million for each year and
so that's what and it's only the self
um
um it's only the general fund portion
that we suggest anything that is paid
with other funds essentially
if the agencies have how to pay it then
that's that's they can pay it but we
worry about the uh the tax what we call
what we call the tax supported debt
okay so that's the one that we typically
pay more attention to right so if we
borrow 120 billion for the biennium
million yes sorry 120 million for the
buyer yes million
um and we pay back
66 or something yes is that because six
is interest and six and
and 120 is
re-going the principle for the principle
yes
um
what's our current interest rate on this
kind of debt budget itself has the
breakdown actually I should have it has
um is principle and interest it's just
not the obviously the budget um
at that level doesn't have the detail
but
um so for example for 24
yes 42 42 million is going to be
principal and 20 million is going to be
an interest
so so yeah so I I guess to
to answer your question or or in general
we paid
um we have us we structure our debt in a
way that we can pay
more principle during the first 10 years
60 of the principal as paid during the
first 10 years and the other 40 percent
during the other 10 years so this is a
20-year Bond so we try to have this more
aggressive way of paying our debt and
that works really well for us this is
one of the things that I I mentioned is
a
um the benefits of the state it's it's a
credit positive we call it because the
rating agencies like the way we handle
and our debt management our policy how
do you have us do you have a sense
if we had an extra 100 million dollars
say um if we put it towards retirement
saving retirement
um unfunded liability versus putting it
in the um rainy day fund
would it be sort of a wash as far as our
our credit rating goes or is it not
quite or what do you think the the
rating agencies would like to see more
money in the rainy day font and the
reason for that is because they wanna
they wanna make sure that our state is
prepared for the next next downturn so
if we have our capacity which is the 10
of the unrestricted Revenue
they would love to see that amount and
the rainy day fund the unfunded
liability
along with all of our debt in general we
are a low debt state is is so compared
to our expenditures and our revenues the
amount that we have it
in total of that it's it's just we have
a very lower ratio so it's it's a very
good um position that we have so they
would rather see us increase our
reserves to be prepared for the next
you know a time of concern or any
emergencies that will come up
again the the the liabilities are not
high compared to in our overall position
of the state okay now
would you say the last few years was an
emergency did it affect the the uh
unfunded liability at all
the unfunded liability of the state of
the pension I mean the um the rainy day
fund yeah so for example for example yes
that's a great question so when we had
um the economic downturn in 2020
um the rate indices were expecting that
all states were using money for from the
rainy day fund because that's the time
where you want to use it when you
Revenue performance when you were
expecting a deficit that's it that's the
that's the time and that's how the law
is written to be able to do it in those
times
um anything else is not really an
emergency you have other you know if you
want to use the money from the rainy day
fund that's really not called an
emergency so that could you know that
could
raise questions as to why that's
happening we could always try to justify
it but uh but you know it again it
really has to be that and the law allows
us to do that just for for deficit
projected deficits and um in uh when
Revenue sign up before so did you see a
dip during 2020 in the rainy day fund so
so the way the state handle it
um that's when the governor froze higher
in and that's when we had to um some
agencies were asked to reduce their
spending by 20 so the way to stay
managed expenditures we didn't have to
tap into the rainy day font so that was
well seen I mean the way we were able to
manage our our operations and again we
had a um to the point that one of the
rain agencies gave us uh you know right
now we have a positive outlook and
that's sort of the step before
potentially we get um an upgrade so
um again it all has to do how we manage
further questions from the division
representative evil thanks just uh real
quick so what is our rating at this
point from the rating agencies for a
bond yeah so Moody's is double a one SMP
is double A and for fetches double A
Plus so twist close to the highest is
one
it is excellent yes
representative kimbrells thank you Mr
chair just secure our city question uh
and the abandoned property division uh
how long do you try to reach the
rightful owner and is there a limitation
and after which you get to keep the
money for for the state
yes thank you for that question so for
the Vandal property program we we
received a property from from the
holders and the status says if we can't
return that property within three years
we um
we as cheat funds to the counties and
the general fund however the rifle
owners can always come back and ask us
for their money so what we do and that
will lead me to my next
piece of my my presentation
um if I can find My Documents now oh
here it is while you're looking for your
documents they're just going to back you
up a bit on our indebtedness yes so on
page 169 uh you paid off about 55
million in 22 and I see that in 24 and
25 we're adding in a little more than
five million dollars you're assuming
obviously the governor's budget and
there are a number of items I guess he's
put in there to bond could you give us a
list of those projects that are causing
that number to elevate itself yeah so I
I could certainly give you yeah you'll
have to do it to now but you know right
but I think I could probably give you
the reason of the difference so I think
I think so that the 55 million is low so
in general our debt Services declining
in in what is happening right now is so
so actually the activity in 22 has to do
is has two reasons one is we did a
refund then we should re we we should
refunding Bonds in 2021
2020 and when we did that we achieved
significant savings that were applied
for fiscal year 21 no 2020 and no I'm
sorry 21 in
22. so we saw so with that because we
essentially removed Prince we removed
some bonds from the market we paid a
significant amount with those refunding
bonds so those uh Debt Service savings
we again we apply them and fiscal year
21 and 22 and that was about 11 million
dollars so with that sort of
restructuring we we that's the that's
what you see The Debt Service that we
pay that's sort of the result of that
refunding the other thing that is
happening is we as I mentioned before
we planned or we say we we're going to
issue about a 60 million dollars in
bonds
but but that but that didn't happen over
the last couple of times we issued bonds
the reason for that is one when we were
having the pandemic the governor also
froze Capital expenditures so we Bond
based on spending not so much we don't
say we're going to bond 60 million this
year we bomb because what we do is we
spend
the spending occurs we only issue once a
year and so then we we see how much has
been spent over the last six months and
we say okay we're only going to need to
bond
30 million 50 million or whatever the
amount is and we also project how much
we're gonna again we're not gonna we
don't think we're gonna Bond again
another year so we we take the actual
spending project the spending and we
determine an amount so those amounts
have been lower than the 60 million and
that's the reason the debt service has
been decreasing so the Assumption of in
2024 and 2025 we are assuming again
we're going to issue 60 million bonds
that's why you see the increase could
you give us those assumptions it's not
today but yeah so it's very simple it's
just as soon as assuming that we're
going to use 60 million and what the
projects may be that gets you to that
assumption
so not now but you know
at some point I don't need you to try to
recall but you know at some point just
give us an idea why it's going up and
what your assumptions are based on
giving us the 60 and 63 million so sure
I can slowly share the products that go
behind that I know the governors
proposed a number of projects and I'm
just curious are they hoping to bond
those I know some are coming out of a
rainy day fund but just a list so we can
have an idea what our bonds costs are as
they may be in here well it's a variety
of things but yeah
clarify so when we when we project this
amount they're not really tied to
specific specific products
um I can probably show you some of again
we look at what husbands spend so we
look at Capital
um expenditures we look at fund 30 and
we see okay these are all the projects
all these ages have spent all this money
so that's that's what we are planning on
bonding so we're about to issue bonds
right now and that's that's what we're
doing we are looking at okay how much
ages have spent how much revenue they
have collected because some of those
projects are fair of funds funded with
federal funds so we take what it's it's
what's essentially just going to be
paired with General funds and that's the
amount we bonds so it's it's not
essentially linked to a specific project
is is more in aggregate like we bomb for
we don't know what at some point we have
to identify what products we have to
bomb because for tax purposes we do have
to make sure that we track those
expenditures for uh for IRS purposes
um but when we're projecting these
numbers in the beginning just to prepare
the budget they're not really tied to
specific projects because if obviously
we don't bond anything I know that's not
the case because I know there's a line
in there for taking money from the
liquor fund in here but there's another
line that says it's coming out of the
rainy day fund for 14 million dollars so
I'm just curious on how that assumption
I mean again don't you don't have to go
any further now but just okay it's give
us something so we have an idea how you
get to that assumption okay because to
me it should be going down if we're not
bonding many projects or depending on
the size of the projects but yes so so
it will go down so this is a very
conservative assumption so in reality we
use this number and likely if we if we
don't bond that we wouldn't want to bond
more than that but if we don't bond that
it just lapses right
right but yeah
further questions represent evil I just
remember
um when I was on capital budget we used
to get confused because we thought you
bonded by project which isn't what you
do at all you just sort of
do this aggregate
got almost kind of a thing it's exactly
that we don't we don't look at specific
project it has to so once we Bond we do
have to specify what Pro and like our
bond documents include a list of
projects
um but those and this is going down into
the weeds but those could actually be
swapped for others if for example if
some projects take too long to sometimes
you know again we take spec expenditures
and if a project started and all of a
sudden is delay for whatever reason and
we need to you know for again for our
for our Arbitrage rules we need to
verify that the money gets spent so if
the if the agency is not spending fast
enough we need to swap what's behind the
bond to make sure that we are funding
projects that are really moving so we
have to always monitor the projects that
are part of those bonds that we issue
but when we are issuing bonds
um we take a less that we think is going
to be funded with that money
but that could be flexible
thank you
thank you for taking my question I think
I'm probably asking it prematurely but
maybe it'll be an introduction to your
next section
how how big is the abandoned property
number
um
well I think overall and I just asked
that question recently
um in total I think we have about
three million 300 million dollars in
unclaimed property in total
um some of it has been as cheated to the
general fund as I was as describing
earlier but I think in total that's
that's the number
um
again when when you know if if that's
property that was received
um I don't have the number exactly of
the property that
um
we've had for three years not not as
cheated yet um but I can certainly get
you that number
um and if I met Mr chair if I could
probably continue that way I could
probably describe
and you don't have to get you know
um just need to make sure I take all my
all my questions with me all the
questions when they yeah so so the next
section it was um I guess this is a
request and the treasury doesn't really
have a requests often and but page six
um we're we're asking for the first time
we're asking
to budget the amount
um it is what we we call in the law is
called subsequent
um subsequent claims and those are those
claims
uh the the money or the fun the property
that has been is cheated to the general
fund we as I mentioned before we do
return the property to any person who
comes forth asking for you know they
found the money we we do pay that we we
do pay that money but the current the
the way we've been doing it the way the
structure currently currently reads is
um there needs to be approved by
government Council so
every
time government executive Council meets
we have to go and ask for the
authorization to so that so the
controller can issue a warrant for money
so otherwise otherwise not appropriated
and to be able to give his authority to
pay those funds and that has been going
on since 19 since 1985 and
um
this is the first time we're asking to
put an amount and the budget is really
the amount that we're asking is 2.6
million which is
um about this about the month that we
pay every year
um relative to this post SG claims and
the reason we're doing this is
um
first of all it seems less transparent
or it will look be more transparent to
show the amount that we pay if we
include it in the budget the second
piece says sometimes it just takes too
long to issue this check so if we have
to wait two weeks in order to to issue
these checks the claimants will like to
have their money A little bit sooner so
that's one reason there are times that
the executive Council only meets once a
month and during those times those those
folks have to wait even longer about a
month for for their checks so by
providing the authority to have the
money and the budget and giving us
authority to issue those checks as soon
as we're able to verify that that's the
right person then we'll be able to make
these payments and so this will require
a change in in the law so that was
including household to the governor
agreed to do this and um this will help
obviously the public will be better
customer service and what what we're
suggesting here is is to um
you know if the one point if if the 2.6
million dollars is not enough we can
always go back to
um the fiscal committee and the governor
Council to to essentially ask for more
money but again is the law that allows
us to pay these funds in perpetuity this
would just facilitate and make it more
efficient to to be able to make this
payments more timely and to you know
obviously this folks as soon as they
find they realize they have money they
didn't know they had they want to have
their money right away so this will help
with that process
questions on this item absolutely
representative
Griffin
thank you thank you for taking the
question
um so after a period of three years see
a street law
comes in to date does that change the
list or is the is is there a public list
and Does it include
all the abandoned properties since the
original the state law was passed
you know so every every October so so
yes as part of our requirement we have
we we publish we issue a publication so
every year in October we we issue a list
um and then the union leader we use the
unit leader to prepare that list and um
that list contains all of the new
property that we received during the
last reporting year so that led to the
newspaper that you see in the union
leader every October only includes the
new property the rest of the property
you could always find that by going to
our website so on our website we have we
now have the ability
individuals and businesses and anyone
can go to our website and search for
property and and they'll be able to find
out property since the beginning of time
now now we can also issue claims so the
the you know the the individual and the
companies can actually initiate claims
right online so we've we've improved our
technology in order to allow that
um and then also individuals com
companies can always go to
missingmoney.com that's also linked to
our missing money come as a place say
you know it's for property all over the
country and but now there's um because
missingmoney.com has a new vendor and
that's the same vendor we use for
unclaimed property system now when
someone searches in that website that
claims comes directly into our database
and we're able to issue that immediately
and then we just need to verify that
that's the right person
hope I answer your question for the
question represent Griffin represent
Maguire
thank you Mr chairman so is this the
money
um we're talking about under current
expense on page 172
um the money that we're talking about is
on page 166
um that is called
um
it's called return of general fund
deposit and that has always been in sort
of housed in my office but never
appeared in the budget before so this is
the first time that we actually budgeted
in an amount like if you look at our
statement appropriation so the
accounting system you're gonna see
um what has been actually the expenses
right there so the fiscal year 22 shows
an amount of 2.6 million
um obviously the fiscal year 23 is
showing nothing because we never budget
or anything but with this new biennium
we are we are suggesting asking if we're
able to budget at 2.6 million in every
fiscal year
so there'll be corresponding income then
to this 2.6 so as general fund so
because we have exceeded this money to a
general fund essentially
um we need to take it back from the
general fund
well yeah so let's go to page 172.
is this a different this is the same
I would love to fix this too but I think
the number in
um scheme is a little bit uh has been
there for a long time
172. so so that so page 172 is is
the um
the cost of the division itself so
um that is what is really just the
administration of running the program
that's what that is and it's paid yes so
so the law allows us to pay for this
cost
from the abandoned property that we have
yes
but that's the property that hasn't is
cheated to the general fund once it has
changed to general fund the sort of we
have sort of two buckets the previous
cheat and the process cheat and the
Prius she pays for the cost of
administration the the the other money
that 2.6 is is general fund I hope I
explained myself well well we had a
fantastic flow chart of how
adequate education when the governor did
his presentation you saw this flowchart
of how adequate education is calculated
right is this plus this plus this minus
that maybe in this area we could make
some kind of flow chart that
goes from here to the general fund down
there you know something like that
because I'm wondering this whole area is
three million dollars spending right but
half of it is current expenses
is that checks going to people or is
that something else no current expenses
is we have contracts with auto firms
they're the ones that do Audits and they
participate in this state this um
Nationwide audit so for example
um they are firms that go all over the
country to find holders of abandoned
property so sometimes these firms
um they audit these insurance companies
and their multiple states that
participate in this audit so for example
so so then these other firms that we
contract with
um they're the ones that um you know do
search records of companies and they
determine this is how much you company
or all of these various States so
they're multi-state Audits and that's
what we bought it in this current
expense
um we we bought it a large amount
sometimes we don't because we because we
contract with multiple firms there are
about 10 firms right now and sometimes
and we only pay them when they find
property they're on a retainer
um
type contract and so if they find
property we pay them
um 10 I think is is around that
percentage of that of of that property
they find so we don't know how much
they're going to find every single year
but we have to budget enough to try to
have again and have enough money to pay
them when they come back to say okay
we're bringing you all this property
it's time to pay us
but it looks sorry proposing it it looks
like we're spending three million
dollars per year to return 2.6 million
to people yeah I mean and that the 2.6
million is only the general fund portion
we we return about between six and seven
million in total each year oh okay in
this this three million total cost is is
is to run the operation I don't think
it's just the whole department or the
whole section it's it's the division but
yes so current expenses is significant
but again that's the reason we we um
that's the reason we we just have to
build it in a way that is we're going to
have enough money that 3 million is in
total yes for that division but um we
collect from in general every year we we
collect or we receive property of about
20 million each year
we don't get to return it all is so it's
we return some between six and seven
million each year
um the rest the general fund gets it
and okay so we need to see the line
where that 14 million is coming to the
general yeah I can certainly provide you
with a different presentation I I wasn't
how the how we how that works how much
we achieved to general fund the formula
perhaps you will want to see what's
involved in that absolutely thank you
we're kind of an unruly bunch here so
you never know what's going to expect
happy to come back happy to be here all
afternoon
representative kimberles yes thank you
Mr chairman so I'm assuming you you
mentioned that there's about 300 million
that's being held that hasn't been
returned to the uh owners yet I'm
assuming you're getting interest on that
if it's other than an account and if so
um do we get to keep any of that
interest or the does the whole the owner
get the interest on top of the money
that they were owed originally
great question the owner doesn't get the
interest so
um
they get their property but not the
interest so so no we so the jail so the
state benefits from that so the interest
is is we invest that we invest that
money in the state keeps it
yeah and just out of curiosity what is
it invested in a relatively conservative
type of fund so what are the percentage
returns because 300 million if you get
10 interest is 30 million a year but I
doubt it's 10 percent so once this is
cheated to a job fund it really doesn't
it's not segregated it's all part of our
poo cash so our pool cash is all
invested in you know the way we invest
when we have access cash so we we have a
a portfolio we invest in a variety of
types of um Securities but it's all part
of our
um you know strategy how we invest our
operating funds so it's no once this is
to your digital fund is no longer seen
as okay this came from the abandoned
property
so our interest rate right now so this
is what I was sharing with me ways it
means
um last week so right now we're
anticipating that we you know the yield
is going to be about four percent
um in the neighborhood of four percent
and we we think it's going to stay like
that over the next couple of years just
because again we're trying to take
advantage of the market
um
um so we're we're investing in
instruments that allow us to have
um that you know higher yield and within
obviously our boundaries within our
investment policy
unrelated
apparently there's another expression of
Hawaii
so our state prison was built in 1878
and uh so the governor seems to think
it's worn out after 150 years
I know you
I don't know why but anyways and he
wants us to build a 350 million dollar
prison
how should we pay for it
correct question
you don't have to answer that
right I I get to um maybe should we save
should we borrow should we do some
combination I guess you know
it's it's a great question
um so as I mentioned every biennium we
suggest that we should stay within the
120 million
range
so it's 300 million is a lot more than
what we would suggest and again we we
don't really suggest that we just
essentially prepare and we're about to
issue our debt affordability study where
we actually essentially take 120 million
for the biennium we say this is what the
Rachel's will look like will will look
like over the next five to seven years
and we want to see those ratios low the
ratio debt to revenue ratio so
um that's that's what we want to see
because that's what keeps our ratings uh
where they are
um so that's why we stay with that and
then we also know that borrowing costs
are gonna you know they have increased
really and they will probably stay like
that for some time until it's you know
clear when things will change
um so that's a great question I mean it
could be a combination of borrowing and
and paying with General funds it could
be I mean one of the things that we we
are like to say too is
um
when when
if we're gonna issue bonds for capital
projects we also have to take a look at
the
um the life span of that particular
project so sometimes now we're using
bonds to pay for it costs so hopefully
those it costs are going to last longer
than 10 years 20 years because we issue
bonds for 20 years a prison likely will
last us a lot longer in 20 years so
perhaps that could be you know a
possibility to bond for 30 years not I'm
not suggesting that but that again
because of the type of
capital investment that we would the
state will make so that could probably
fit
um again depend you know so there are a
variety of options that the state could
consider
um to do that
you asked that question
um so what are the interest rates you're
anticipating us getting on our bonds
yes that's a great question too
um
so I will probably like right now that
I'm the four percent range
um so the municipal Market is different
than obviously a getting a mortgage
um so it all depends on the uh the
municipal Bond again Market
um we issue bonds
um in series so some of them are five
years 10 years 15 years 20 years and
they all have different rates
um the shorter and of or the shorter
short-term rates are
um are higher than the long-term rates
like the 20-year or less
so I guess in on average it could be
about four percent that's what we're
thinking
um
because I that that would be my answer
right now it could be less
um does our rating affect the interest
rate that's what I thought it does so
um we get a better rate if we have a
but not by much right I mean if we were
you said we're next to the top right if
we were the top
that's like an eighth of a percent or
something right is it it's not a lot it
does it varies and it depends on the the
time of the market but uh it we've we've
been very fortunate New Hampshire has um
we don't we only issue once a year and
so investors like our bonds so when it's
time for us to issue we've been there
for tonight and the bidders give us a
very good rate so
um so Soma could say that we get we
could look like a AAA type issue
um it all depends on the market but we
you know again folks that want investors
out there that like to diversify that
like our bonds for sure
so
but in terms of the the spread and the
difference between
um that depends on a variety of factors
and and the time of the market too but I
can provide you with some information if
you like to see you know just the
difference I don't have it right now but
yeah I mean they're comparable States
Mike that's right are there are there
comparable states that have a similar
yes and yes and again I don't have that
list right now but but in terms of um
the rates are very specific like the
market dictates typically okay this is a
triple A rate today this is a um you
know double a rate today so they they or
or obviously last one what they call
junk junk bonds so they have obviously
different prices per se
um so you can certainly see what the
market really dictates so how those
rates look like yeah I'd be curious
about Maine specifically because I know
their retirement system is in better
shape than ours
so and I don't have I can certainly get
to that because I do have I do get a
report where I get all of the state's
ratings
so moving on to the distribution moving
on distribution I can't even say the
word it must be too tired
so uh distribution to municipalities
there we go yeah so this is just the uh
the the amount that is is housed in our
budget and this is the meal syntax
distribution as you all know the formula
changed during the last biennium in
um so so that you can see that the the
the money going to the municipalities
has increased
um it even increased
um
six increase even more and
23 because because of the the way the
formula is written the way the statue is
written it just it just gives them more
um
it gives them it gives them less than 20
50 or 22 and then begin in physical
security
um the way again the way the statue is
written it just it just
the funding is higher but then it stays
about the same going forward let's see
what's 16
so I see your note here it says that the
governor is suspending
the distribution
Stacks distribution that's that's stay
and that is now funded with a dedicated
fund
um
that was maintained so that was
um continue to be lost here 166.
um so yes so and so the governor did
include the amount that we calculated
and this calculation for fiscal year 24
in 25 included
we obtained information from the
Department of Revenue Administration and
the the to determine how their estimates
on the meals and room stacks and we just
built into this formula a two percent
Revenue growth the same as two percent
um
expense growth because the
as part of the formula the the the
cost to administer the the meals and
room Stacks program
um they can deduct that from that
calculation so we just included the two
percent assumption for both revenue and
expense growth assumption and that is
um the 121 million and 24 and 123
million and 25 is what the formula
calculates
um
the the what what what the governor
removed was uh the state of Revenue
sharing this is an amount that's still
this
this um I guess mandate is still in
statute so we have to budget at every
time but one more time the governor is
suspending the law and House Bill too I
have not seen the the the language but I
was told that it will it will not be
part of our budget well it's not in the
budget so it was removed
so that's what that
representative
the state of Revenue sharing so many
years ago
um the Year this this the state used to
pay 25 million dollars to municipality
municipalities
and but that that amount has been
suspended over the last biennium like
probably last 10 bienna
and
correct that's the second that's the
second amount that in the past
municipalities used to get from the
state they both part of our budget but
the meals and rooms again this year was
funded in the past it was capped for
upper to a particular amount but then
when this formula was
during the last biennium the formula and
the law was Rewritten and so it's been
fun it has been been funded has been
funded since then but the revenue
sharing amount and we included 25
million our agency budget but that was
again
so if we change the suspension to a
repeal it would make your life easier
because in your agency budget you would
never have to think about this thing
that that is correct right that is
correct because you haven't we haven't
but I think for municipalities hopes
so that's that's that's that again
that's you know another item sitting in
my budget and so page a is just briefly
touching on
um
the college savings commission this is
this is um
we renamed that activity code before it
was called unique
um
I'm not even checking around my house
call exactly but so now it's called
College events uh commission it really
is
um the portion of the budget that the
college Teresa Savings Plan advisor
commission it includes that
administration of that commission we so
we provide administrative support to
that commission and what is part of this
um this accounting unit is
um the the scholarship funds that flow
through our budget essentially the money
comes from the what we call the New
Hampshire excellence and higher
education trust fund is kept separate
but in order to because it's much easier
to send payments to universities through
the accounting system we use this part
of our budget to essentially facilitate
those payments so that's what's been
used since this I guess scholarships
were created in 2006 and so that's
what's holding that's what's part of
this commission the the other item here
is the governor scholarship fund now
that fund is funded with General funds
that is a program that came to the
advisor commission a couple biennia ago
is part of our budget last year this
last biennium this program wasn't funded
it or the I think the house the house
removed we requested the money the house
removed it from the budget
uh it was around the Senate phase that
it was decided that funding was going to
be given and that funding was provided
through House Bill 2 so this program was
funded that way
this time around we the advisor
commission again approved to request
three million dollars for each fiscal
year we included that in our budget and
the governor approved that so it was
three million for we requested three
million for each biennium now going back
to what commissioner Goulet was saying
that there's some inconsistencies the
month so the money that was because we
included the governor scholarship budget
and the priority prioritize needs
and I don't fully understand how it
happened but the DUI T portion
um the class that was funding the doit
amount which again those those costs
came from the uit for us to put in our
budget for some reason that didn't make
it
um everything else made it but not the
portion that we asked for DRT so we
would like
to ask as if with those those small
dollars get put back into the budget so
that's what we are including I'm
including here in page on page eight we
requested six thousand a hundred and
eighty two dollars for fiscal year 24
and 6 357 fiscal year 25. and again
somehow they got removed and
um but we included that and again that's
the piece needed for to fund the uit
expenses
and the last two pieces as
um we also have a um this Ben Thompson
trust fund expenditure that is just an
amount that we transfer to the
university system in New Hampshire from
the come from this trust fund and the
other two are the l-chip program and the
Community Development proc block grant
those are also past programs they just
housed in my budget and the treasures
budget the l-chip
and collaboration with the ill-chip
authority their requested five million
dollars and so we included five million
dollars and the Community Development
Authority asked for 200 000 and that's
what we include in our project
so that's what I have for presentation
I'll be happy to answer any other
questions you may have
further questions
represent people
my plan if all goes well I'll issue it
sometimes next week so you you I can
certainly send it to the entire
um division we typically send it to the
chairman or chairs but I can certainly
to ever send it to everybody else
absolutely
happy to do that
should the could the Corpus of this
trust fund be transferred to the
universities of endowment and then they
could
pay themselves from it that that's a
great question we've had discussions
over time about that so what I
understood from a department of justice
is
they could work with us the division of
charitable trust they could work with us
to change
the purpose they need they can go to
court on our behalf and we could they
could be this there's a possibility to
do that and just simply give them the
entire trust because they are the
beneficiaries of it so it could be
possible to do something like that we
just have to engage and do work with
it is worthwhile as it is in my long
very long list of things to do but yes
yes
so I I believe it has nothing to do with
a bill I believe it's just uh the
department adjuster will have to just
um submit a request to the court to
change the purpose of the trust this all
is separate then
um than legislation
yeah we check with representative Weiler
the two of us have served on the
commission for years I stepped aside to
let Margie Smith take the position but
it has been debated she comes to the
commission every quarter
to let us know what's going on but what
do we had by 19 million dollars we gave
out last year or something towards uh
scholarships and those are different
this is this is the difference
30 percent of my wire was speaking about
the Ben Thompson trust fund oh that's
still above then I'm sorry I'm not
paying attention that's okay and I I
don't really have I don't really have
how much money we have in that trust
fund I can I can get that number for you
but what we transfer to the university
system is this small amount and it comes
from a very old law in the 1900s that
um when the state
misspent the funds and it was added to
the law that we needed to pay them on a
quarterly basis so we still do that
um
my apologies I was still up on the
commission reading through so yes and
seeing not a long week is over
thanks Phil very much I don't think we
need you to come back to see us but just
some of those questions and maybe like
representative McGuire had the uh a pie
chart idea as far as showing the
breakdown flow chart pie chart for
abandoned property yes so I have to I
have to write down all of those um
oh perfect excellent
so yes I'll be happy to come back and
and either provide you with information
provide it to the LBA or or I'll be
happy to come back yeah if you could
send it directly to the LBA and that
would be great and it'll distribute it
to us sounds good thanks Mrs General
thanks everyone good to see you good to
all right
oh questions what's this
foreign